good morning members good morning
members of the public you're very
welcome here the Smallin we've got quite
a full agenda so we'll make a start
I'll ask Rob our officer to read out of
the health and safety warning please
Thank You chair well first remind you of
all might remind you all of some
domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area opposite
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room following the fire exit signs and
meet on if switch town football club
training pitch and please do not
re-enter the building until you were
told it is safe to return could I please
ask you to switch off all mobile phones
or tenant aside thank you thank you but
- sorry though the official wording I'd
like to read and mind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
slowly to the Internet and will be
capable of repeated films the hold of
the meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential and accept papers
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for the
webcast and and/or training purposes the
cancel members of the public and press
may record film photographed or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded I
don't believe we've had anybody indicate
that I don't think anybody's asked to do
the filming so we'll take it as okay
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you have
finished and to the members of the
public who do public speaking later on
this morning
can they get quite close to their mic so
that everybody can hear if you sit a
long way back
take this over you can't hear so well
thank you
[Applause]
item one substitutes and apologies Thank
You chair we have apologies from
councillor ferret counsel Hinton and
councillor Norman thank you
do we have any apologies substitute
accounts of the days yeah I'm standing
in for council to join Hinton thank you
very much okay I'm standing in Council
thank you we don't have a sub for
canceled aberrant thank you
declarations of interest No thank you
very much we'll move on to item three to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 12th of February cancel urge yeah
I just need to say that I have I'm chair
of the ships of traveling traveling
amuse you and that comes up Joan on the
theory that I should have interested or
something can you tell us what what
again repeated please which and if them
councillor Aires would just say again I
think the Chairman would like to hear
precisely what the the role is and I'd
and okay I'm chair of the Egyptian
traveler committee and the steering
committee with MS Lupo go
chairman the councillor Aires and
councillor Parker's spoke before the
meeting it's it's properly declared as a
non peculiar interest there's no reason
why the members shouldn't carry on it in
this item a your faces they can carry on
but I think our low council Parker to
register his interest could that be
right and proper
Thank You Chad yeah I will then declare
any local non-pecuniary interest insofar
as I am a member of the gypsy traveling
steering committee thank you thank you
very much that's noted you can continue
remaining thanks Larry
sorry yeah can I can I do the non
peculiar because I'm on the committee as
well please okay thank you
all those three are noted we'll move to
item three to confirm the minister
meeting held on the 12th of February
you've all had copies of them I will go
through them every day the page numbers
stop me if there's anything you wish to
comment on page 1 page 2 page 3 page 4
page 5 page 6 page 7
page eight page nine page ten page
eleven page twelve page thirteen this
post at the filter and I've now sign
them as a true record proposed by Ken
[ __ ] Osbourne's seconded by instant
Jennison all those in favor
thank you very much
[Applause]
item four do we have any petitions yes
sir we have two petitions sir for this
meeting if you just bear with me and
I'll just get the details so the first
position to report is regarding the
application d c-- 1902 9 1 when bentley
and that just read out the statement of
the petition which is object to the
planning application d c-- 19 double O 2
9 1 of housing development as brought by
code development planners and the land
at the land west of Church Road Bentley
Suffolk following reasons are of concern
to me infrastructure village character
wildlife and safety and as signed by 250
invalid signatories the second petition
to report to committee today is
regarding the first application on the
agenda which is DC 1904 9 to 3 foot with
the following statement we the
undersigned residents of monks Ely and
surrounding villages are strongly
opposed to the establishment of a gypsy
and traveler site on land north of
second Pitt's Highlands Road Nancy Lee
we call on Weber and mid Suffolk
District Council's to refuse planning
permission
this land is situated in a very peaceful
rural area not near any amenities and
close to a listed building it should be
maintained for agricultural equine use
and is completely unsuited to use as a
gypsy and travelers site and that is
signed by 111 of Alexanderplatz
signatories thank you very much for that
we'll both those who noted and will come
up through the closeness thank you
item five site inspections officers do
you have any to recommend no members
nope
thank you very much then you have next
Wednesday the 4th of March off you
haven't got to report for site
inspections thank you
it's spring coming along so bear that in
mind
item 6 plan and applications to be
determined by the committee we have four
in front of us today a is landlord for
second Pitt's Highlands ceiling right on
page page 19 and the officer is Daniel
Cameron over to you
Thank You chair there's nothing to add
to the report in front of members today
by way of tabled papers or late papers
so everything is are set out in the
report within the report itself I just
want to draw them as attention to a
typing error point six point three on
page 29
I of course meant to give members an
overview of policy see no.1 and the MPP
F with regards to design criteria
hopefully members are well versed with
those policies and the MPP F in any
respect but I just wanted to make you
aware that that's my error that's made
it through to the papers today before
you if we look at the tation
so yes the application is for a single
gypsy and traveler pitch on land to the
north of second Pitts Highlands
rhodomont Ely the applications made in
full it before it would allow the
sighting of one gypsy in top of the
bridge and that bridge would comprise of
one mother on tutoring caravan
and it would also include the erection
of one day room in terms of planning
history on the site there's already
planning permission been granted on the
site for the erection with stables and
for the stapling of horses and grazing
of horses on land as well the sites
located 2.5 miles from Brent Ely one
mile from luckily a one-pot one mile
from cattle Bastion
the site is isolated from services and
facilities and likely be highly reliant
upon private Motor Vehicles to access
services and the development is also
held to be harmful to the serving of
Wagga farm which is a great a listed
building approximately 100 meters to the
north of the site the recommendation
before you today is to refuse the
application on heritage grounds on the
basis it doesn't represent sustainable
development here we have an aerial map
with the site highlighted in purple we
can see within the map both Wagga farm
here and then second pits here we'll
then move on to the constraints map the
site falls within special landscape area
that's identified as flowing along the
banks of the river Brett and the river
box it's described within your landscape
guidance as a trunk is having a trunkful
tranquil rural feeling is mainly made up
of agricultural farmland with isolated
farmsteads
within it although we do know a number
of historic villages we also know that
the orange mark on microphone just to
notice it's a great - listed building
and the site location plan marked in red
and I'll come into the planning
background of the site in a little bit
more detail the stables located here for
members as well as a paddock land an
access is already approved under
previous planning applications this
application would
simply deal with the sighting of touring
caravans here in her mobile home and a
room that be increased planting her on
this boundary here
everything else is shown within the
application drawings are already on site
with regards to the day room it's a
fairly utilitarian building square plan
brick and clay plain tiles is designed
to allow additional outdoors the
additional internal space fees you know
ancillary to the touring Caravan or
mobile home for sort of those sort
utilities or domestic purposes you might
not want to undertake in that if we just
go now to the map the red point
indicates the application site this is
just to visually illustrate the
connections to the various villages
cattle Basten's up here to the north
monkey lien Charlesworth there down here
to the south and then we have Brent Ely
over here South and West just gonna
quickly run through this site
photographs for you members this is the
view down Highlands Road from the access
to the site we can see the fencing
denoting the change on the horse box as
well here's a view across the site
towards the river we can see some of the
outbuildings associated with like a farm
just here for you members and I've also
got an image later that shows the
relationship to work a farm itself in
terms of a listed building here's the
existing access already in place and a
view over the remaining site this is if
you back up along pylons row towards
monte Li you see the road inclines up a
hill and then turns and then this is the
view of Waqas farm from Highland Road
this is the farmhouse itself here
largely screened from a site by the tree
and that's it for you members
everything else is us out in the report
I'll pass back to you if you have any
questions arising from the detail thank
you very much for that we have public
speakers present today members the
parish council as you know we - parish
councils are involved in this so they
have three minutes each and that will go
all the way through to all the public
speakers the supporters the objectors
applicant agent County can start and
ward members right the parish council
catalyst that we heard from Sir Robert
Butler and Angela Faris Mancini if
you've both like to come forward
together and take the place of the front
payer and when one of you start we'll
start the timer and there'll be three
minutes will I'll stop you at the end of
that and then the next one can take over
and at the end of the six minutes I'll
serve members got any questions to you
so please members bear in mind that our
ask your questions at the end of the
four six minutes so you do have to get
them write them down you know when
you're ready
monks Ely parish council wishes to
object to the planning application for
the following reasons one the land is
not within Muncie resettlement areas as
defined in the core strategy plan in
2011 to the site falls within a special
landscape area designated by Weber as
identified in section 15 of the local
planning policy framework the proposed a
room mobile home and two touring
caravans are entirely out of character
with the area and the SLA designation 3
the application does not meet the
criteria for policy CS 11 strategy for
development of hinterland villages which
one cities one these specifically refer
to site location the village is a mile
away and localized
I'd need there has been none number for
the application does not meet the
criteria for quality CS 15 which states
the proposal should respect the local
context of character landscape and
heritage assets a development on this
site would have a large impact on Wagga
farm a great - listed building 5 the
application does not meet the criteria
for policy cs20 the location of the site
in relation to facilities it is a mile
from a shop but three miles from school
and medical center excessive
accessibility to the village pram Lee by
nan car transport modes the Roadster
access monks le are very narrow and have
no footpaths there is also no public
transport available whatsoever and six
the council considered this application
as a single pitch gypsy and traveler
site the document gypsy travelers
traveling show people and both dwellers
accommodation needs assessment for Baber
May 2017 this states in accordance with
the revised DG d c LG definition august
2015 for planning purposes the
accommodation needed for found needs of
family who have permanently cease
travelling cannot be considered as part
of an assessment for need of for gypsy
and traveller pitches but in addition to
this looking at the requirement for
resident residential pitches 2016 to
2036 table 6-4 which is a summary
doesn't identify any need and till the
period 2000 31 to 36 and then for one
pitch monks ely parish council therefore
wonder if the guidelines budgets in
travellers sites apply for this
application and also as Bober has
identified
no need for additional sites we
recommend that their application is
rejected thank you right when you're
reticent and first I'd like to say the
Parish Council agree to the
recommendation of the planning officer
to refuse the above planning application
in the council's view the proposal does
not meet the criteria set by many of the
planning policies any potential benefits
are minimal in comparison to the
significant environmental harm that
would be caused by such an unsustainable
scheme as commented by the planning
officer in summary our key reasons are
as follows
why don't we fully endorse plan officers
conclusions that the significant harm
landscape and environmental harms
associated with the proposal
significantly outweigh any benefits so
we would draw your attention to the
council team comments from the fire
service and highways team these suggest
the installation of additional fire
hydrant are long distance from current
provision and the Highways Department
would mandate the provision of an extra
pass in place both measures would
involve significant works and costs and
serve to highlight the unsustainability
and unsuitability of the site through
national and local planning policies
including the planning policy for travel
sites are designed to promote prevent
unsustainable development in the
countryside and are supposed to preserve
and enhance the character of the
countryside in this case the site is not
really in a in open countryside but sits
in a part of the Bret River Valley days
designated special landscape area as
such this river valley rightly enjoys
additional protections from new
development the landscape assessment for
the area specifically refers to the open
valley appearance ethical area and the
unsought river meadows which contribute
to the visual quality of the landscape
as the planning officer has correctly
pointed out in his report the remoteness
of the site from even the most basic
facilities facilities means that there
would be an absolute reliance on private
motor vehicles to access any and all
services with the nearest health care
and schools being some miles away and
secretary schools being many miles away
we would also like to point out in this
regard that with the Baber and Suffolk
councils having quite rightly declared a
climate emergency in recent months
approval of an unsustainable development
such as this would fundamentally
undermine both councils pledges on
sustainable development and achieving
carbon neutrality locally by 2030 and
naturally within 25 years we also agree
with Mr Cameron's and the heritage
team's comments that this application
would cause serious harm to the great to
Mystic building known as Wagga farm with
the use of alien materials we further
know from the report the applicants
agent has suggested that adverse impact
could be mitigated through conditions
around materials this would seem
impossible for static and during
caravans in conclusion the council
considers the development to be contrary
to many planning policies cited by the
officer as it is damaging to the
protected landscape and to the setting
of protect protected heritage as assets
it is environmentally unsustainable and
a suggestive benefits are both minor in
comparison and questionable we strongly
recommend the application is rejected
thank you thank you very much for that
members have you any questions for the
two speakers no
thank you thank you very much
we then have objectors we have two John
Doe and bran Rowling if you both like to
come forward and take the seats we'll do
it in the same order one of you go first
will then stop you're after the three
minutes and the second one can then take
over and at the end I'll ask members
that they've got any question I'll stall
you thank you okay clarification points
Thank You chairman I act for the two
local resident families at second pits
and Wagga farm your case officer has
presented a very full and balanced
report in our view he has covered all of
the material points in in a very
balanced way we are very much in support
of what has already been said by the
parish councils and I don't propose to
repeat any of the detail of what they
have already said there as far as we see
the matter there are four points to
emphasize in this case the first is that
this is plainly an unsustainable
location this is simply the wrong place
for this type of gypsy and traveler
accommodation second there be clear harm
to a valued landscape in this case I'm
echoing of course what's in the report
and what has already been said by the
parish councils thirdly there would
clearly be harm to the setting of a
grade 2 listed building like a farm
that's not just a matter of policy as
members will know that's also a matter
of law section 66 of the listed
buildings and conservation areas act
special attention has to be given to the
setting of listed buildings and fourth
in this case and of course something
that your case officer gives careful
attention to there isn't in fact a real
need made out because this particular
applicant family are already resident on
a lawful [ __ ] and traveler site this is
not one of those cases where one can say
that there is a pressing need
to accommodate a family that presently
doesn't have anywhere lawful to reside
just one point if I may with regard to
the recommendation which is made on page
31 of your agenda as I've already said
we agree very much with the analysis and
the recommendation of your case officer
subjected us this one point perhaps it
would be helpful to include just one
additional line here in the
recommendation which of course will give
rise to the reason for refusal if you
decide to accept the recommendation
perhaps there ought to be a line that
says expressly there would be harm here
to a valued landscape this is special
landscape it's in the report it's in
what has been said by the parish council
but there wasn't actually a line in the
recommendation that makes that point
specifically I appreciate that by
implication it's covered by CS 15 but
perhaps it would be wise just to include
that specifically thank you very much
thank you much for your time before you
commence
mr. alley I will get the officer to
comment on that point at the end of your
six minutes before I get member stars to
questions okay Thank You mr. alley
Thank You mr. chairman well what I like
about this application as it is flawed
inconsistencies which are enough in any
event I think for the application to be
rejected out of hand from my point of
view the committee's functions do not
include considering flawed applications
forgive me but your place is to protect
to promote the well-being of the
residents and while that does include
minorities it does not allow minorities
to tyrannize the majority and here I
think they apply the bending principles
of what needs the greater good the
application suffers from very serious
inconsistencies
for example we are for turtle as it is
for a total of three homes on site very
parking for one
from one Lightfoot vehicle the
application states there are no trees or
hedges on the land but the plans and the
supplementary letter indicate otherwise
more importantly the application
indicates that found sewage will be
disposed of by septic tank but the
adoptive plan indicates the septic tanks
in these circumstances are not
appropriate the application states there
will be no gain in residential units
which begs the question why is the
application why is the a become
bothering the supplementary letter
identify as an immediate need for one
pitch in paper and from memory this need
has already been met in use linear
Sudbury the 32 to 49 residential pitch
is needed in the wider area which is
mentioned in the application covers hips
which Baber mid Suffolk Suffolk coastal
and Waverly
apart from beta none of these districts
need concern after day so ladies and
gentlemen the application is flawed to
the point of being misleading it
actually provides a solution to a
problem which does not exist and should
therefore be rejected and I call on you
all to use your common sense and denied
this application Thank You mr. chairman
thank you very much I will save mountain
birds have got any questions to you just
answer one point that an applicant has a
right to apply for planning permission
as they see fit
and we're duty-bound if it ticks all the
boxes for the officers to deal with it
when it gets to that stage so I hear
what you say but those are the facts we
have to work by members any questions no
thank you very much gentlemen
now get the officer to reply to that
request of add additional point or the
reasons for or not thank you I'll use
this one yeah yeah yes chair we tweekin
in terms of the home to landscape mr.
camera has already identified that as a
sub clause of the other policies but
there's an explicit policy cro4 which we
could reference in there is refusal so
in other words it's been put out there
as an idea if my if members are minded
to refuse and to go with the suggestion
of a gentleman then cro forbid
irrelevant policy right and you're not
proposal to put it in but if members
asked for its firm innocence idea thank
you members you're clear on that we have
no support we don't have an applicant or
agent unless if it turned up late no or
counter can't slap so we'll lose onto
the ward member penciler Harlan you sir
have up to ten minutes because we have
the double time but you don't have to
use all ten minutes but you do have ten
with us thank you thank you chairman I
couldn't possibly fill two minutes
probably three will suffice today I
think I should give compliments to mr.
Cameron the case officer who has handled
this which is a delicate case he's
handled that brilliantly I feel it has
brought at all the salient points as the
local ward member I think my main
concern is the ecology of the site there
may not be many people in this far-flung
place but there's a lot of wildlife and
things in the grass by the river it's a
bit of a floodplain and that would
concern me I'm not adverse to having the
odd house in the countryside to help the
sustainability of the village but I
think even I would probably fall short
on this one I wouldn't allow a house
built her I wouldn't support it and I
think what's proposed strung out rather
sort of hotchpotch
does worry me also chairman the fact
that to these things the Turin caravans
and couldn't come and go will be added
to I think we could be setting yourself
a difficult problem for the future and
possibly an enforcement nightmare I also
have to think is this the correct place
for this family to live I hear there are
seven children in this family which is
lovely under all primary school age and
haven't had two children in the middle
of the village and become a permanent
taxi service that it I do struggle to
see how this is going to work
there is no village school anymore which
would have worked they would have been
glad of the numbers but since that been
closed three years ago it will be
difficult for education purposes for
normal general things that families do
it would just be a massive massive sea
of car journeys up and down a very
narrow lane and we do have to bear in
mind we are moving into different areas
environmentally and quite honestly I
think this is a wrong place for a very
large family to live it it is beyond the
back of beyond really as you've probably
seen from the photographs and well I
always value different lifestyles and
tend to support them I think for ecology
reasons I think this won't be good and
for the environment for green travel
which cannot be achieved
I think it's wrong it's a wrong place
for the family to live anyway and I
think it's not a local family if they
were already in the village I might be a
bit supportive but they're coming from
outside the county I understand with
nothing wrong with that but I do feel I
do support the Planning Officers
recommendation for refusal quite
strongly chairman thank you thank you
very much cancer Harlan members is there
any questions of clarification points
you wish to put - no thank you very much
right members no until general debate
who'd like to start
counselor Karen can you get hearing
about Daniel I was interested in the
presentation that you gave and I was
very interested in the representations
that came from the public
I'm sorry members can't hear you can you
get closer you haven't got laid fully so
that the caps you can try and show I'm
being polite in terms of the
representation I was a bit taken aback
it's on page 21 and the final and the
final of the view that was expressed
that the person lost the circumstances
of the applicant are key to the proper
consideration of this application and
should be open to public scrutiny I
found that a bit difficult to accept and
I wondered whether when you're screening
objections and letters from the public
if there is some process in which I find
that remark quite inappropriate and
considering it was on the District
Council's website so they thought
available to the public
is there no process in which our
procedure that unacceptable comments can
be removed we thought being put to the
general public
Thank You members
counselors refer to page 21 the button
punt okay so in support of their
application the applicants and the
agents provided some details to the
personal circumstances of the applicants
and their children because that went
into personal detail it was held that we
needed to make that sensitive we're
still under certain duties with regards
to gdpr and you know we are still
charged with controlling that
information despite the fact that it has
been submitted to us that has been
available for officers to to look at to
scrutinize but it's not it's not
necessarily always appropriate that we
put in the public domain and I think
that comment just noted that because the
agents planning statement which was a
public document noted these the this
private statement that there was just a
feeling among local residents that they
wanted to have sight of this document as
well I think it was a father in our duty
as data controller it wasn't appropriate
in this instance made that personal
information available to the public that
helps penciler Parker yeah Thank You
Chet this this has a particular interest
to make this application because I
happen to live in the the only other
village in the boca district that
actually contains a formalized travel
loss site at Newton and I can say with
absolute certainty chair that a lot of
fears that have been expressed
throughout the report in terms of
sustainability in terms of you know
damage to the heritage si etc etc the
cider Newton is actually extremely
similar to to the situation that we're
looking at here and I can say that that
that science coexisted with with the
with villages without realizing any of
the fears that have been expressed
throughout the report so that lets that
not just make that point however at
paragraph three point one six
it does say that the needs assessment
which was completed in 2017 does indeed
and it was mentioned one of the
speaker's mentioned it does indeed show
in need of one pitch within the district
within the plan period so could you just
clarify for me is that one additional
pitch or is the existing pitch what is
required
I'm not aware of the application of you
so you probably better versed them than
I am to know when that was brought
forward and when the use on that site
was begun my understanding from the
gypsy traveller traveling show people
and both brothers accommodation needs
assessment is that within the period
2017 to 2036 there is a need for one
additional pitch within baver district
in terms of the delivery of that I think
the speaker from the parish council is
correct I think that is probably
bookended towards the back of the plan
period but there's nothing to say that
if the suitable site comes forward
before that time members aren't allowed
to consider whether or not they would
like to see that approved and brought
forward and additionally although the
need is for one site again members if
they're so minded can support more than
one site we could provide more than the
minimum required need from the needs
assessment I think that's within your
gift any other comments members
Chancellor puzzle you needs interesting
questions in it we've identified that we
want one extra pitch and therefore that
assumes that there's only one set of
travelers that are going around at them
for a pitch if you live in cot dog
capable or poor do you'll know that it's
not the case because frequently we get
five to ten travelling bands turn up in
these areas because presumably there
aren't any pictures available for them
to go to
so you'd question the need with a one
pitch ball satisfied from my point of
view I think it's it's fairly
straightforward thinking it feels
house that we were looking at in this
position we wouldn't accept that either
it's not sustainable it's in the middle
of countryside okay and I'd been I
haven't got a problem with some houses
individual houses in villages if it
helps maintain or keep the village alive
in this case I think it's just in the
middle of almost in the middle of
nowhere doesn't have anything going for
it so whether it was a house or a
caravan or whatever it is I think it
would be no thank you
any other comments members Chancellor
Parker yeah I concur actually with cow
suppose we notwithstanding my previous
comment so you know the facts of matter
is we do now have a local plan and the
plan policies are quite clear and you
know personally it's it's it's regretful
that we can't take a more open view of
the situation but nonetheless the
policies of what the policies are chair
so I think that the officers
recommendation is absolutely spot-on and
I think I'd like to propose that we go
with the officers recommendation on this
occasion Jen thank you very much Spencer
Parker do I have a seconder councillor
Ayers
yes I totally support carrots and a
purpose comments and yes I do have every
sympathy from them but this is not the
right place as I support it
you heard the comment about the extra
[Music]
yeah
family landscape and the policy number
is cro4 do you wish to add that to the
recommendations counselor Parker or not
well chair I mean it's it's not in the
recommendation at the moment
can I ask the officer in their
professional opinion do they feel that
it would that had would it add to the
validity of the recommendation as it
stands it is that necessary because we
shouldn't put on conditions which are
not necessarily required I do agree
there with you can you answer ad all
right the officer that so hootie-hoo you
can do there are arguments both ways the
CR CS 15 talks about mitigating hunter
landscape in any case so we sort of have
covered it I think the comments for mr.
dog are right that would if we want to
expressly draw out the harm to the
special landscape error as well we are
able to add a sentence that then brings
that out and if we watch to reference
cro4 for completeness then I think this
time I think the point more is that you
chose not to put it in and you've
covered the reason why you didn't put it
in then you don't feel that's necessary
I think that's what you've got to no way
up counselor partners to whether you
think that's necessary oh you want to
comment go on them yes I just added it I
mean it's there's no just special
landscape area certain it's it's it's
it's all valued landscape that gives it
a higher bracket of consideration so if
you're thinking that way you could add
it special notes gonna be looks low if
it's back to your counselor Park up
there I think it's a great idea I think
we should add it okay thank you very
much and as a seconder do you wish to
support that still you do okay thank you
so it's been proposed members by
councillor park on centre by councillor
Ayers that we accept the officers
recommendation with the additional
policy cro4 all those in favor please
show she's Animus thank you very much
that is carries thank you snow on the
case
[Applause]
members the next item is on page 30
failures the case officer is Jack Walt
listen he's supported here by Louise
Barton backstop our house who just waved
please city jet hey listen who's going
to support the office up in this so if
you have any questions regarding that in
due course okay thank you very much
over to you jack
thank you for that can you can hear me
very well the members of the public
there perhaps if you'd like to come and
sit on those two rows in front of the
glass and we'll see whether you can hear
better thing there yeah what about the
people at the back yes you can you hear
well right then I think the seats behind
the glass don't have any speakers so
we're you're all sitting now there's
speakers out so you should be able to
hear behind the glass right no speakers
yeah yeah right those members of the
public that's sitting right at the back
if you want to come forward and join
these people in there where your bear to
hear back up because we can't do
anything about the sound but we'll note
that and ask our office of Rob here to
take that away and look at it but
Stewart at the back can you hear okay
good we'll just wait members for the
public to move
right members perhaps I could remind you
again to lean very close to your mics
when you're speaking so that we can try
and make sure that the public can't hear
us where we were I think over to Jack
you were going to take us through this
thank you
Thank You chairman good morning members
members of the public I'm Jack Wilkinson
I'm a principal planning officer for
baby mid Suffolk the next item is item
6b on page 35 of your papers and it
relates to land west of Church Road and
Bentley the proposal is for outline
planning for the erection of up to 45
dwellings shared foot and psychopath and
access so in terms of site location
we're in the south southeastern area of
the district with Capel towards the
northwest it's switch to the north up go
12 and colchester south along the a12 as
well in terms of the defined redline
outline is as shown it joins the village
to the north and is a 2.8 9 hectare site
I'm going to zoom back out as well just
to give you an idea again of how far the
site extends out from the main body of
the village now this is the defined
built-up area boundary for the
hinterland village of Bentley the
application site is towards the north as
hatched zooming in again there's
slightly further this is the proposed
joint Local Plan settlement boundary
outlined in pink which you'll see it
goes around the entirety of the village
it doesn't partially include part of the
application site in terms of other
constraints got a defined open space to
the west on a central piece here
there's also which is forgive me it's
slightly faint but there's a public
right-of-way that operates along the
western flank and indeed the
northeastern flank
as it leads into the center of Bentley
in terms of additional constraints the
green hatching is the special landscape
area that is defined and the land is
principally agricultural in nature
mainly to the northwest and beyond those
areas to the eastern edge as shown and
the southern edge we have the main
backdrop of the village certainly there
is an appreciation for how the landscape
speaks to the village and vice versa
this is quite an open area and I'll
provide some photos in a moment just to
give you an are wider archit a wider
view of the landscape so in terms of
fixed details again this is an outline
application for 45 units this is a
parameters plan now this shows the
developable area here set in orange the
green area shows the open space along
with associated utilities such as water
attenuation and other utility services
that would be associated with the build
I'm going to go through some of these
details just to give you an idea we can
always flick back to it should we so
need to another fixed element here is
two proposed access there's no issue
with the axis from the Highways
Authority and your officers concur with
that once we take a look at some photos
later on you'll appreciate as well the
edge of site here which fronts
residential dwellings and indeed to the
south as well there's good established
hedgerows and this land at the minute is
all like a cultural land the actual
boundary appears to be delineating by
furrow so I'll go into that in a moment
whilst this is outlined we need to
consider the extent to within which this
extends from the main body of the
village
and there's also the potential within
the proposal not just for two-story
units but also to an off story that may
be a focal points but it is a fixed
element that's included so we must
consider that just to finish off to the
south
there is a pedestrian cycling that's
proposed that would largely sit along
the back of existing units running to
the south and any proposed units to the
north you may have to see power to point
to of the reports so going into the site
frontage we have some main photos that
shows the maturity of the trees and
indeed that verge which is running along
the eastern side again you may wish to
follow the arrow marker along the bottom
left here which shows where these photos
were taken from approximately and the
access would be along the left-hand side
here opposite dwellings on the
right-hand side this is the access point
so this is the most southeasterly point
of the application site as you can see
here the access would be slightly in
from that and zooming in this is the
configuration to local highways
Authority standard so I'm going to take
you through some photos just to show you
the topography which isn't too clear and
again apologies where the red marker is
is the roof of the vehicle my car when I
went and visited on site the land slopes
down as you come out of the village and
you can see that incline so as you're
coming out of the village there's the
primary school which carries on up this
road and if you relate at the minute and
the school is approximately where the
marker is I'll show you later on
stepping into sight you can see the dip
towards the northeastern corner that's
quite a good shot actually because it
shows the contour and this would be
where the lower lying land is this tree
line here is the backdrop of Bentley in
terms of the village boundary you can
relate to the map that shows that mainly
turned off at the minute of agricultural
nature here's the western boundary of
the site and a view looking across and I
suppose this this shot is probably the
most useful in outlining how open the
site is we would need to consider this
and certainly there are concerns from a
landscape perspective of how open the
site is and how well it could integrate
this is asking for 45 units that could
potentially be up to two and half
stories high in in places so we need to
balance that in in the overall decision
[Applause]
more views across the site this would be
the approximate position of the public /
slope and foot path along the southern
edge
and a similar view of that eastern
boundary so back to the map it's prudent
to go through an assessment of whether
Bentley in your view would provide
sufficient service services facilities
and amenities and as a means of
highlighting that I'm gonna drop some
figures on that shows what is where so
effectively we have the primary school
towards the Northeast we have Baptist
Church hairdressers stores public house
the case is altered and the community
shop and the eagle-eyed amongst you will
notice that there's a red dot as well
now this shows the nearest bus stop
there's also one on this corner here as
well but that's not the nearest this is
a nearest which is where the red dot is
shown so I'll take the marker away now
in an assessment of whether this site is
capable of being supported your officers
don't believe that it can be based on
the fact that there isn't sufficient
services and facilities to enable a
scheme to be supported for up to 45
units there needs to be places for
people to live and work and to sustain a
reasonable level of domestic option in
order to live that being said there is
the bus stop option however this service
is extremely limited at best so that's
been factored into the overall
consideration so final summary here are
some facts and figures for you to
consider there is an element of
discussion within the report that I've
gone into at length around the
affordable housing now typically the
benchmark minimum requirement from
policy states that 35 percent should be
provided now the proposal includes 35
percent however there's a slight caveat
with that insofar as that it could be
delivered across this site as option 1
or option two which is the preference
from the applicants is to provide 35% on
this I and another I split across two
sites I've referred to this as the
Station Road site the Station Road site
does not benefit from planning benefit
from planning permission it's not
established and I can't rely on that at
this stage in order to deliver that it
would be set within a section 106
agreement that would fall away if
members were inclined to approve this
application now that's within your
papers and I'll be happy to discuss
I suppose it's prudent to move on that
the recommendation from your offices is
for a few of us set out on page 61 and
62 of your papers this relates largely
to the principle of development
landscape impact and sustainability
thank you thank you thank you very much
for that forum with support we have
members of the public here parish
council which is mobile Breathitt
[Music]
yep thank you I think this is a distinct
worse system and I recall last time I
was here but anyway good morning
chairman good morning members thank you
for hearing representation I'm speaking
as chair of parish council on behalf of
the council and residents the village
first with became aware of this
development in November 2018 when it was
presented to the village it was a
meeting it was well attended and
generated significant feeling and you it
will be evidenced also the nature that
feeling from the petition which you've
received it was - considered in its
original form in January last year and
after an extrordinary meeting and a
decision was made to recommend refusal
largely on the grounds of CS 11 this is
an a large development outside the
built-up area and there is no no
justifiable need that was presented or
can be evidence to date it would
represent a 13% increase of the housing
in the village there's already a 10%
increase accepted and/or under process
of being built and therefore it would
represent overall 25 percent just about
increase in a hinterland village
hinterland of the Kapus of Mary where
the current local plans suggest 5 to 10%
is appropriate over the next 15 20 years
as the committee we aware of the already
proposed large developments in Capel
which is the host of this cluster it was
also recommended that it should be
rejected on the grounds of CS - in
respect of its impact on social and
physical infrastructure and there was
already problems with the health
educational and transport infrastructure
and water and surges services it was
also considered unacceptable on the
grounds of CSL their RCS 15 with its
impact on the special landscape area as
is and the projected local increase in
the boundary of the area and be to
include parts of the village and its
impact on biodiversity and highway
safety particularly was emphasized this
is exiting on to a singletrack Lane
which is the principal access to the
school and the church and generates
significant traffic at specific times
which is could be hindered by traffic in
and out of the site and we take
exception to highway safety report the
the application was represented and had
an item removed which was the provision
of a school drop-off point and this
makes it significantly worse from my
point of view the village has had a
landscape assessment as in process of
its construction of its neighbourhood
plan and Alison farmer as emphasized and
to quote it would impinge on the
application would impinge on the subtle
valley topography and have a an
urbanizing influence in the ground sorry
your time is now I thank you just like
propose reject the questions for you
from members PS 11 yes to cs50.net the
public in Qatar members have you any
questions no thank you thank you very
much monday an objector
[Applause]
thank you I'm here to represent the
objections of Bentley residents as
highlighted by Allison farmers landscape
report the site has key qualities that
make a notable contribution to landscape
character and have a medium to high
sensitivity to this type of development
proposed the topic topographic variation
within and adjoining the site means that
development will dominate the landscape
despite the landscaping proposed on the
plan and the effect will be harmful on
the rural lanes and foot cars that
surround the site on three sides the use
of public rights-of-way is a valued
recreation in Bentley from responses to
our neighborhood plan village
questionnaire they are considered the
second most important facility to
village life and significantly in
contribute to our well-being visitors to
our village use these footpaths and
enjoy far reaching rural views which in
turn supports our community pub and shop
this site is within the setting of the
revised boundary of southern coastal
he's a an OB and is just 430 meters away
from the development site the
development the sewage pumping station
an infiltration Basin will be highly
visible from the elevated views of
footpath 40 the harmful impacts on the
scenic quality of the area cannot be
overemphasized the natural beauty and
tranquility that public rights-of-way
users currently experience will be lost
as regards to bus service let me clarify
there is only one service per day now
that only serves the knee
of Suffolk - students there is no a
service that is serviceable for getting
into its which for employment we eat
don't even have a bus service that
connects to our core village of cables
and Mary so we have no sustainable
options for living and working needs in
our village Church Road itself has been
highlighted as a single track rule lane
with few passing places and no footpaths
for most of its links this road is also
being considered for designation as a
quiet lane this development could
generate at least 90 additional vehicles
trying to access this rural Lane as well
as extra delivery vehicles that are
creasing Lee used to deliver goods
direct to people's homes
this will increase safety risk for
walkers cyclists and horse riders who
use this narrow lane as well as pupils
who walk from the primary school to some
Mary's Church not shown on your map
several times a year Bentley is not a
versatile development and we are
building houses in the housing needs
assessment prepared for our neighborhood
burn it recommends 38 there's any
questions for you
members Chancellor Davis I was
interested in that point about your
neighborhood development plan so could
you expand on that yes because we are
considered a complex site and we've been
given extra resources to have special
consultations done for us both for
landscape and for a housing needs
assessment and AECOM who have done a
housing needs assessment have recently
just supplied us with our final version
that has been reviewed by locality of 38
houses over the plan period thank you it
was very useful
any other questions members Chancellor
Busby
Yates houses over the period being did I
think Michael said that they'd already
done some yes yes we've actually since
the first of April
2018 we've built ten houses and we're
planning 31 more so those are actually
planned houses in the village and we
hope that we will have more more
affordable homes in association with
hastow homes as well very good
cancer possibly yeah having been one of
those people that walked round your
village yesterday and fell over in the
mud but we won't go into that walked
round that site the the road is
flattened out on the photographs it's
very difficult to get REME so it no to
push you for a question
yep just it looks like that road might
flood does it does that it does happened
frequently the an actual fact the bottom
of the site below the site in Church
Road has been shown on national flood
maps to be subject to surface water
flooding at high risk of water flooding
and we have got pictures of children in
canoes paddling across at the bottom of
to get to the primary school that has
been improved recently because the
farmer has done a lot of work to dig out
the local ditches but we are still
concerned about the effects of surface
water flooding with this development
thank you must disappoint the children
any other questions
nope thank you very much we don't have a
supporter we have an applicant Helen med
cot if you'd like to come forward we
have three minutes in which to address
the committee at the end of it if you
remain seated or standing on our surface
any questions for you thank you
yeah sorry Thank You chairman Thank You
members my name is helen Adcock i am a
director of code development of planners
the applicant Don Baker is a local
farmer who owns the land adjacent to the
north east and southern edges of Bentley
built-up area boundary he lives in
Bentley and he has bought his family up
and his children have gone to Bentley
school he therefore wishes to ensure the
new homes for Bentley are of a scale and
form that meet the needs of the village
and which can be delivered in a way that
doesn't with unmitigated restraint put
pressure on the services of the village
services an infrastructure of the
village this is one reason he has
progressed the application himself so
that rather than a developer promoting
an area of land and seeking to maximize
the developer area the full extent of
the site's constraints opportunities and
the needs of the community have been
explored to ensure that the developer
area respects the landscape setting the
trees the opportunities to increase
biodiversity surface water drainage and
highways and the opportunities for
community benefits the applicant wants
to ensure that the development can
deliver what is needed proportionate to
the village and within the bounds of
planning regulations landscape has been
a subject of the landscape visual
appraisal undertaken by a qualified
Landscape Architect and the findings
have been endorsed by the planning
services landscape officer who has been
the Consul T of Baber District Council
and they raised no objection to the
proposals I draw your attention to the
were legit not letter that was put into
the late papers yesterday in relation to
a phasing condition and the
marketability and viability of that if
you consider here today in your
discussions that due to the landscape
concerns a phasing condition would be
appropriate that letter demonstrates to
you that it would be viable and markable
to the developers need is discussed
within the officer's report and it would
appear that with the amendment to the
section 106 heads of terms in relation
to affordable housing
this could overcome the object
in relation to the developments ability
to address need the appeals referred to
in the officers report have been shown
on the map in the attacks late papers as
being some way distant and isolated from
the village itself so we believe that
those should be discounted from your
consideration whilst it might sorry
whilst it might be a scale of
development that some within the village
are seeking to resist it is a scale of
development that fulfills a demonstrably
need in accordance with the relevant
policies of your local plan and policies
of government infrastructure has been
demonstrated and set out and the
officers report to be suitable for the
delivery of the proposals and no
objections from the main statutory
console TV Riz no evidential reasons for
the refusal of this planning planning
application that's before you today
happy to take questions thank you chair
thank you thank you very much there's
any questions members councillor Davis
I'll do two at once if I main that'll
make it easier for you first of all the
affordable housing contribution why not
just say it would be 15 in that area
rather than try and offset it somewhere
else and be we you in your applicant
aware of the Neighborhood Development
Plan which obviously contradicts quite a
bit what you've just said I'll take the
first question first
in terms of affordable housing it was
actually a recommendation or suggestion
from officers of baby district council
back in 2018 to split it across the two
sites the applicant can and it is within
your gift as members here today to
discuss this to say yes actually we're
minded to approve this subject to the
section 106 heads of terms being amended
to only have the one option that it's
35% fully on-site that that's within
your gift and it would be something that
the applicant would be happy to go along
with like I say it was a suggestion from
officers back in 2000
Dean seemed a reasonable one at the time
but like I say think things move on in
relation to the local plan yeah not our
local plan but the the Bentley
Neighborhood Development Plan yes sorry
sorry in relation to the neighborhood
plan just checking some dates in
relation to what the chair of the
Bentley Parish Council said actually we
had meetings back in 2017 September 2017
with representation with representatives
of Bentley parish council we then
followed that up with another meeting in
July 2018 before the application went to
their parish council meeting later on in
2018 for the application after we put
the application in so we have had
dialogue for a long time with the parish
council as we have done with officers of
Baber in relation to the neighborhood
plan at the time that we started to
prepare the application and do all of
the reports and stuff to assess like I
say the constraints and opportunities of
the site the neighborhood plan area had
only just been defined and in terms of
the neighborhood plan process itself
hadn't progressed to a stage that would
and could have influenced the
application and whilst members of
Bentley Parish Council are parting to
the neighborhood plan and what's going
on in the background actually publicly
we haven't seen anything or been party
to anything or had any discussions that
I think has to stop do that I think
you've answered the question regarding
the neighborhood plan thank you very
much there's somebody else in had a
counselor Jemison my question was that I
was canceled Davis on the affordability
so it's being covered any other
questions councillor Busby
oh yeah the second site for the
affordable housing is that if that site
proposed site owned by the same farmer
and if so why didn't be put in a
planning application for that at the
same time if they if the two will live
so both both sides are owned by the
applicant the Station Road site is being
progressed by hastow so hastow
approached the landowner and it is for
them to run their own application the
application for west of Church Road is
being run by the lander and himself
where as I understand that the station
Road site would be run by casting thank
you any other questions I just have one
if we were minded to approve this how
quickly would you start on site we would
obviously because it's an outline
application we'd have to put forward
reserve matters and they would be done
in connection with a developer as you
were seeing from yesterday in college
and not as agents for the landowner is
on board and is confident that there is
latent demand for such a site and that
the developer could be found quickly and
an application for the reserve matters
could be put in quickly so in terms of
delivery subject to whether you go for a
phasing condition or not we could start
on site within the next 18 months so
we're still at the early stages there
thank you
Oh cancel Buzzbee yes what I think house
he needs survey did you do any kind of
yes so as part of the application
material that's in front of you and all
your ability to look at we've done and
housing needs survey done by pioneer
which is part of the papers so and that
demonstrates
you'll see that document in your papers
that's demonstrates that there is a need
for up to 45 dwellings within the
village so and I you know what I wasn't
clear about is whether that came across
in the officers report because it seems
that with the housing need in the
officers report he refers to affordable
housing
this document demonstrates an evidence
that there is both market need and
affordable need within the village
cancer the Busby officers TV Harrison
officers present I think at the end of
this will put that question to her and
so you can comment on it for you okay
any other questions no thank you very
much thank you I will go straight to our
house and the officer strategic agnostic
you heard that comment from the last
speaker cleaning and the document she
held up can you comment on it please and
yes as far as I know that's not a
primary data that's just an assessment
of existing so except Andheri data
assessment it's that correct yes in
terms of the CS 11 requirements that
housing these report it is a response to
the requirements under cs 11 and they
were also in response to the question
about the two sites my response was an
objection to that proposal to split it
across the two sites and on the on the
evidence that was presented we could not
support that in strategic housing and I
must say that looking at the reports
that have been provided it seems to
propose that the affordable housing will
be delivered by the applicant on the
rural exception site that's not actually
true it's just the land that is being
given overall yeah
provided I have spoken to her snow
housing on that point I just wanted you
to understand that thank you do you need
any other car we'll come back to you the
said the upper corner was just that
point I wanted to clear up think we
don't have any county councillor present
wanted to speak councillor Busby is the
ward member but he's chosen to remain a
member of the Planning Committee and
he'll take part in the general debate
which we were now carried thank you very
much yep
thank you this counselor possible I just
carry out with a pick up the point
officer V you think you'd spoken to
hasto recently could they have they
explained why they haven't put in a an
application for that and I can't
particularly comment on that point in in
as much as I just know that there if you
like waiting to see what happens with
this application but there is no option
agreed there is no formal agreement in
place it was just some discussion that
took place quite a while ago and
probably in 2018 when I wasn't involved
on this English site and I think you
know just waiting to hear what happens
on this site but it is a standalone
Brewer exception site that was being
looked to be delivered by the Parish
Council they've done a lot of work on
that in conjunction with mid stuff again
haste oh they did a local needs housing
survey that was carried out by a
Community Action Suffolk and that has
identified a need for a rural exception
site whereas this site that's proposed
if they wanted to provide that across
two sides it's not something that we
were support we believe that there's a
need for a small scheme which is a rural
exception site and
this standalone other main site should
be capable providing 35% and the issue
were having the other side involved
should really be the case
thank you no questions Fenster Parker
are we now into Bateman Yeah right
okey dokey so can I just thrash this
business out about the affordability
then in that case because I mean it
seems absolutely clear from from what a
strategic housing officer is saying and
and indeed with something very similar
in our own village in terms of
development with hastow but it occurs to
me but it's in know why relevant to this
application at all at this stage so I
don't know if we're late if this is
admissible or not but miss had cough
sent us a very late submission last
night as committee members and I just
want to thrash this business about that
therefore this this deliverability of
affordable housing being over a split
side is that correct then that it was
our officers recommendation and if it
was why yes this came up in brief and so
canceller I'm sorry object if you like
to answer it for the Quetzal
thank chairman and thank you for your
question Castle Park I think the option
is there however we have to determine
what's in front of us and if we've been
plain and simple what is before us is
the scheme that I've presented but also
there's no guarantee that the Station
Road so I wish I could pick a reference
to it but we haven't got an application
that's approved so you'll have to come
to your own conclusion on whether you
consider that to be a reliable source of
achieving 35 percent across two sites or
whether we should deliver this if your
money to approve on site in its entirety
through a section 106 there is the
capability of doing that and if the
Station Road site is not approved then
that element would fall away from the
section 106 and be provided on this site
hopefully that's clearer it's a little
clearer it is complicated yes but I
you got the picture cancer the Davis
yeah I've got a little bit of sympathy
for the developer in terms of when they
started there's this whole application I
think a lot of things have changed
they've moved on I agree with what Jack
has just said about its two separate
applications you pick the absolute point
and just looking at this application
there's so much against it in terms of
the affordable homes if you like its
location one of the other things that
probably wasn't in the pipeline at the
time was the the change of the
boundaries within the a OMB and and as
you know I'm an advocate and we're
signed up to the a OMB it's important
that that we don't just pay lip service
to it but we actually take action on
that and this has been pointed out by
the residents the proximity of this
development to that so that's another
reason and the sustainability obviously
has been well documented so for all of
those reasons all the recommendations by
the officer I'd like to propose that we
accept the officers recommendation to
refuse thank you very much
as it says do I have a seconder for that
cancel a plan do you wish to comment no
thank you any other comments members no
right broke this as Dover comments then
members have discussed it there's been a
recommendation for refusal following the
officers recommendation it's been
seconded all those in favor please show
real animus thank you very much
we're now onto page six Council oppose
me I was trying not to look at him
yes counselor Mosby oh you wonderful
you've been that brave don't you that
should be back by sorry past 11:00
you
right members were passed in session or
on see which is on page 60 failure and
the case offers a Bradley happen Thank
You Jerry good morning members ladies
and gentlemen this application before
you or this proposal is seeking
agreement for reserved matters following
the grant of an outline planning
permission for residential development
on a site capable sent Mary my point
there is just floating over capable sub
Mary Parish just to give you some idea
of where that is in relation to the
overall administrative area the site
itself is abutting the village on this
northwestern sorry northeastern boundary
and there you can see the existing
residential development adjacent and
also some residential development along
the old London Road and the line of
butchers Lane which isn't actually the
proposed means of access to the site
that being little toughest which is off
the estate to the left-hand side this is
the constraints plan which you'll see
mainly consists of areas of tree
preservation order which aren't
effective by the site itself there is a
heritage asset there is one listed
building near the site which is roughly
where you see the red dot apart from
that there isn't anything that would be
directly impacted the other thing useful
thing to point out is the line of public
way which goes in on butcher's lane and
then returns across to London Road and
the other useful thing to note on this
which you couldn't see on the last slide
is a newer residential development which
has taken place adjacent to the site
which is known as boundary Oaks this is
the proposed site layout which you can
see takes form of an access off of
little Tufts which is the existing road
to the left-hand side and is a series of
coldest acts cul-de-sac and perimeter
blocks and development and you'll also
know that there's two areas larger areas
of open space it's the south north of
the site a suds attenuation area and
incidental incidental areas of open
space within the site itself this one
gives you an idea of Story Heights the
majority of stories being - which is the
green two and a half which is the orange
shade they're all the this or ready
shade you can see there there is one
instance of three story development
which you'll see in due course which is
a block of apartments here and in the
north western corner of the site there's
single story development this plan shows
the affordable housing layout we felt
was important in terms of how that's
distributed across the site that it
shouldn't form a particular cluster that
should be part of the overall
development incorporated as such the
amount of affordable housing as you'll
have noted from the report was
established in the outline planning
permission at thirty-five percent and
this meets that requirement this plan
shows the layout we've just been talking
about but also includes the area to the
north the open space and indicators on
there you can't quite see the writing
and apologize but in effect that's
saying that society proposed site for a
leap local area of a quick play
which is a requirement again or
something that came out of the outline
planning approval so that's the proposed
site somewhere in that area rich H blue
in terms of the the proposal itself as
you can see is traditional vernacular
architecture of starting with a slide
that shows one of the affordable housing
units because again in terms of visual
impact or you shouldn't be able to
discern one from the other private from
public details such as arches and
casement windows and such are carried
across both ten years so you'll see on
the the private affordable unit sorry at
the public sorry the private unit the
detached unit here it's the same sorts
of detail that you would get on the
affordable ones again there's a lot of
work gone into the detailed design on
these we've had a lot of discussions
with the applicant in order to try to
drive the design up and make it an
appropriate response to what is an
important item near to the village so
we're happy now with the proposals they
carry around details around the building
and our own arches and traditional
features such as chimneys and some of
the units which again in overall terms
help lift the overall appearance this is
a unit with an integral garage which is
not the happiest way to design a
building because it's not a traditional
form in itself but if you're going to
have an integral unit sorry an integral
garage within a unit that's probably one
of the better ways of doing it and
having a simple projection on the
frontage and again another unit which
I've included because this gives you an
idea of variety of roof form they don't
all pitch one way so there is gable ends
on two streets which again is a
traditional feature the village feature
another affordable housing unit and
another one again similar sort of fall
two and a half story unit which again
has got dorms this roof space usable
roof space the dormer itself is not over
overly sized for the amount of roof so
it doesn't appear as overly bulky this
is the three-story unit which admittedly
there's an unusual element within the
village I don't think there's other
three-story development in there there's
one instance of it and it's set
centrally on the site as you have seen
but it does follow the traditional
architectural approach and does have
good verticality and by that I mean that
you know the the the use of windows does
mean that it doesn't look like a long
squat building it does have some sort of
perpendicular architectural features and
I'll end with two shots or bungalows
which are part of the affordable housing
offer on the site once a detached unit
which looks almost like on arms house
type design and this is a 70 Touch unit
River with a hip roof both quite polite
and in our view appropriate for a
village location this finally are two
shots of the utility structures one the
substation which is been located next to
a unit and Tufts way and the simple
enclosure where the pump house equipment
itself is underground so in order to
secure that they have to have some sort
of structure around it and again that in
itself is relatively harmful armors some
street views here I think it's useful in
terms of gauging so how the site works
in terms of density because mindful of
the fact that this leads out into the
open countryside to the north it was an
attempt to try to make sure that the
density of development in this part was
lower visually in order to provide that
sort of visual transition between the
two so you will see there's a reasonable
amount of space between dwellings and
again
this long line you see here is this long
line of development here and again it's
quite spacious as you'd expect towards
the center and that the southern half
where where it meets the village itself
the density or the the amount of space
between units is less but again visually
we felt that that was an appropriate
response this gives you an idea of the
view into the new housing area as you
come from little Tufts and it's also
useful to gauge the scale of the
three-story unit which we were talking
about just now to give you some idea it
doesn't sit there too unhappily in our
view that's the two still two and a half
stories scale which again is quite
reasonable in you know ver win at terms
but I don't think that the scale of that
is too harmful in that location bearing
in mind the ogle height and this is a
view looking across the open space to
the north which again hopefully over
time would become more of a landscape
dominated area as as the the landscape
matured but in any event is quite a soft
or a softer approach the development now
I'll finish with some shots of what's
around the air at the moment this is a
typical view of the residential
development next door to the West
this is approach to the site from little
Tufts it's important to emphasize again
that this approach and at the use of
little Tufts to serve the development
has been agreed at outline stage the
actual access itself would take place at
the left-hand side of that post you see
there the lamppost and you'll have noted
from the red line drawing that this unit
and its attendant curtilage is also
owned by the applicant this a view of
the boundary Oaks development which is
newer than the the estate you've just
seen which is more of the
approach or more similar to the approach
architect to approach and layout
approach that's taken with this current
development but it gives you an idea of
proximity and the layout plan that you
saw puts an area of open space
immediately adjacent to that in order to
protect the residents amenity in that
location there's some lovely trees along
the boundary none of which are going to
be impacted the larger one at the end
you see is covered by tree preservation
order already but certainly is now
intention to take out any trees or
hedging because they are an ecological
resource and obviously they're a
resource for the the development itself
a boundary with the existing development
looking across the site to show the the
immediacy of where the the village ends
and the the countryside starts so I
think in terms of the as I said the
phasing of development that we were
looking to achieve in this part because
it will create a new boundary it's not
quite as harsh as that and there's some
units great Tufts and little Tufts
this is butcher's Lane as I said before
it's not proposed to use that for any
form of access to the site Barr
pedestrians and cyclists that was
established through the outline and
pedestrian cycle ways through the site
would link through to that and through
to little Tufts what would happen in
here is that and was established that
the Outland stage was that in the event
that little Tufts access was blocked
there would be an alternative route
through to the site for emergency
vehicles so whilst this wouldn't be
offering a route through you know an
everyday route there would be bollards
placed somewhere along this point here
lockable bollards in order that you know
in the unlikely event the little tuft
was blocked and you couldn't get a fire
engine in there's a there's an
alternative route there were further
views of
that line would you see the the last
thing I draw your attention to is the
type of papers we hopefully other chance
to read councilor carp and dales
comments on the application and I'll
I'll leave my presentation at that thank
you thank you very much well for
clarification good picture of that
against the rest of the sorry have you a
be a picture of it against the rest of
the impacted on on that application on
the on the design of the houses where
it's situated with those on notice you
haven't put it on there yes I think I'll
follow up on that because I made a note
of slowly 21 22 and I couldn't really
see where that was so if you can just
clarify that point before we go any
further
I think firstly counselor the only view
we've got of the three-story building
apart from the usual of a usual
elevational drawing is that CGI which
shows the building there yes yes well
we'll come back to that I think cancel
Osborn yeah okay because I had made a
note at that point and so I'm sure
you're picking up anyway we have public
speakers here so we're going to move on
Matthews you can remain seated or
standing whatever suits you and I'll
service any questions at the end thank
you
Thank You chair the urn I represent the
parish council the parish council has
consistently commented that the building
on this site is too dense and cramped
it's actually 38,000 Specter the Sheila
assess the site as 5.56 hectares
suitable for 75 houses on three hectares
which would be 25 houses packed air
boundary Oaks the adjoining development
is built at 28 houses per hectare and
the existing houses at 21 Hopkins homes
the building 97 in the village and they
are building at 20 houses per hectare we
expect in the joint local plan there
will be an allocation from stock
properties for 550 houses which will be
at 26 per hectare so none are over 30
per hectare there are also two and a
half and three storey buildings
this clan this is not at all in keeping
with cable sent Mary looking at the
housing mix in cable 48% of the homes
are for bedroom and 41% of three-bedroom
our housing needs survey in 2016 and the
Shema identified a need for smaller
starter homes and bungalows for an aging
population the planning statement for
outline permission which was quite a
pretty picture stressed states of the
80% are likely to be two and
three-bedroom this is not true of this
application and that there would be to
market two-bedroom bungalows and to
market three-bedroom bungalow there are
none the planning statement in December
17 stated that there would be provision
of a range of house types and tenures to
cater for the needs of the existing
community as well as for new residents
including smaller homes for young
families and bungalows both the foldable
and market there are not the houses are
smaller 33% of this development is for
bedroom homes there are no bungalows for
sale there's an under supply of
two-bedroom houses by 25% this is not
meeting the identified need for cable
sent Mary there is more open space which
is good the planning officer said a lap
I am under the impression it's a leap
and that play equipment must be agreed
however the open space is next to the
subs which may be fenced or may not
children do climb fences the suds will
be deep and dangerous and will retain
water the parish council had never
agreed with the suds development and
would prefer an underground system which
would allow for more open space and less
dense building the suds is the cheaper
option we can do better for cable than
this development they did get our line
your time is up
pleased to hear that you commented about
the bungalows I had noted myself no
bungalows when he was going through it
but I'll comment later members any
questions to the speaker canceler Busby
you mentioned the needs of the village
in terms of the housing is this as a
result of the what's come out of the
neighbourhood plan survey no I was going
back to the housing needs survey
conducted with cows in 2016 thank you
any other questions nope thank you very
much
thank you we have yet no objector no
support huh
so we have the applicant Asians Stewart
macadam you sir know the procedure so
thank you good morning chairman and
members of the planning committee my
name is Stewart macadam I'm the planning
manager for persimmon Holmes and Suffolk
members are being asked to consider
persimmon Holmes applications seeking
approval of reserve matters for a
development of a hundred houses as
permitted by the outline consent
approved by your committee in July 2018
the development layout Falls key
principles establishing the design
process
instigated at the outline stage and
falls positive pre-application
discussions with your officers during
the course of the application and
following discussions with your officers
and consideration of comments received
by statutory coin sorties including the
parish council and third party
representations a series of amendments
the proposals have taken place
culminating in the plans before members
today the key changes include amending
the internal rod Leo following an
objection from highways an increase in
the size of the affordable housing units
and line with comments received from the
housing officer in cooperation of a mine
strip of wine between the ports and the
western boundary and houses in pain
a three meter high native hedge is
proposed to be planted along the western
bone double se as well the public open
space has been increased to the north by
one hate one acre which is 0.4 hectares
thus providing more meaningful open
space adjacent to the sods pond and I
would note that the such points is
designed to be dry and except in a storm
event and can provide additional open
space further improvements the detailing
is outlined by your officer and to the
detailing of the houses have also been
incorporated into the design the stove
elm is a strong emphasis on Farmer Harry
Zhuang and includes 35% policy compliant
affordable homes there is a wide range
and mix of bedrooms ranging from one to
four and the site also includes
bungalows in flats the majority of the
dwellings are two and three-bedroom
houses the layout is based upon
dwellings formed in outward parameters
blocks over fearsome two blocks re with
enclosure a garden and houses are
designed there are in the peripheries of
the site two frontal into public areas
to provide a pleasant outlook and
surveillance of these areas public open
space forms a central component of the
layout and provides from the tried to
setting for houses whilst accommodating
the principles of sustainable drainage
and an area of play public open space is
provided in the north and southern parts
of the site and provide key focal point
using the objections from the PI's
cancel and third parties are noted
however we believe that the proposals
provide a balanced mix of housing at an
appropriate density for the location
concerns about drainage have been
addressed and are acceptable to the leap
flood authority who has removed it's
holding objection in respect of play
facilities but someone is happy to
accept a condition to secure appropriate
play provision on a designated area of
open space to the north members will
know that from the papers apart from the
Parish Council there are no other
objections to the proposals thanks very
much my salties macadam the target
questions for you members any questions
I think I'd like to ask why no bungalows
there are bongos the full bungle was
included within the scheme on western
boundary for yeah councillor Davis yeah
do you accept that the parking provision
is inadequate in terms of most of the
house if I only got single spaces and
there's very little room you've shown
that the size of the roads very little
room to park on the main road and
obviously that's going to cause
obstruction to refuse trucks that fire
services etc I don't accept darkness
reported in your report that the parking
is actually in excess of the parking
standards so there are 221 spaces for
each of the houses and visitor parking
at 26 the totals to 47 which exceeds the
requirement from highways Thank You
councillor Tyler
mr. macadam I visited the site yesterday
and the officer gave a picture of little
Tufts as if there was hardly any cars
there I couldn't find a parking space in
little Tufts it's a concern to me when
you start the development that is going
to ruin the life of those people in
those hotels there's just not enough
space even now are you going to widen
the little Tufts Road are you going to
compensate the residents of little toes
because actually once you start
development if anybody wants to sell
their house and little Tufts they'll
have great difficulty in doing that so
what what compensation if any are you
going to offer the residents a little
top I would just remind you cancel that
the
open the yes I take your points and I
think there's a part of it that is
outside their responsibility as they
widen that but I think certainly the
compensation bit if you can answer well
I would say is that yes you're quite
right the access has been agreed through
the lane application as part of the
outline approval we have two relevant
conditions on the permission year
wantá-- can supply details of deliveries
to the site 28 days before they are
delivered and also the requirement for a
construction management plan which all
deal with and the tunes of goings from
the site so that will at least be
submitted and commented on by statutory
consultation officers and agreed prior
to commencement of development thank you
thank you the the the other thing about
the bungalows what is interesting about
K preliminary I've lived there for quite
a long time that at one time it had a
predominance of young families what
happened then was parents were joining
their children and living in capable and
there is a need there is a lot of people
incapable who wished to downsize and
there's nowhere else for them to
downsize to so is there any possibility
there might be an increase in the
bungalows cantilever cameras hard before
you answer that you've just stated that
you live a bit of I used to find out how
close to the site and live as to whether
you would have an interest
sorry you'll need to speak closer to the
mic so with me I'm sorry I live the
other end of the village it doesn't
impact on me personally I'm told that's
far you miss thank you can you answer
our questions hi and in terms in terms
of the housing mix here we have had
extensive discussions with the housing
officer
so and they have agreed the mechs are
submitted there was a comment about the
number of bumbles and the individual
might have seen more there isn't a
policy in the Walker plan requiring a
specific mix but what we have done is
provide a varied range of houses from
one to four bedrooms of which 65 of the
units will be two to three bedroom
farmer houses so you know for downsize
and not everyone wants to downsize to a
bungalow they might be moving from a 5/8
house to you and a 2 or 3 bed house and
still want extra bedrooms for family to
come by and stay for example so I've
considered that but we wouldn't propose
to increase the number of mumbles as
part of this proposal thank you I figure
I've just liked safes I had for Simmons
as your fact well away in my village
degree corner at the moment I I have to
say I tend to find that they're crammed
in that certainly it looks that
appearance now as I drove past it
that concerns me on this particular site
why is it you've got permission for up
to a hundred why why don't you can
perhaps consider heaven less than a
Honda I know we've got to deal with a
hundred but what why have you got to a
hundred
why couldn't we have more space around
them and certainly that block does not
impress me at all
three storey which I'm sure cancel
Osborne will be coming to land in a
moment because I saw his hand go up but
can you tell us why is it that you've
gone right to the hundred when perhaps
by having a fool s you could have made
it look better when you know the
problems you have another sites of yours
where they look and I have to say
overcrowded
it's a common channel that I'm sure mr.
macadam would would want to say himself
that them up to a number means that you
have permission for that number and the
up to gives the applicant the
flexibility to go a bit less if they
find it expedient but it's permission is
granted an outline stage on the basis
that are that number is that I'm sure my
colleague will agree oh that's yeah I'm
very pleased to pie today of all the
legal sorry but if you'd like to answer
you may have you feared you don't wish
to do them that's fine I know I just can
come with with what your legal advice as
there is up to hundred and we believe
that we have a development here that
achieves an appropriate density for the
area it's comparable with the one that
has been built off London Lord to the
east of the site twenty-eight dphh was
mentioned in your report that's the
overall the air the density brings it
down obviously what the developer area
pushes our density up slightly but we
feel we've got an appropriate density
and the houses can conform to our policy
requirements
Thank You Chancellor Osborne Thank You
mr. chairman um it's just a couple of
questions really I know
design is is a matter of individual you
know ways of being I you know like
Marmite you either like it or you don't
like it I'm afraid I don't like the way
that the those properties have been
designed in that dark dark area but on
your on some of the on the later images
that you show you show a lighter a
lighter building now I don't understand
why you show one set of houses dark and
with brickwork but it looks at it and
the other ones like the other factor is
that that three-story building ish shown
there
now that's three stories how can that be
the same height it's a two and a half
story that's the first question
I don't have the actual height of that
building with me but the CGI images that
were presented or being is a perspective
view they are accurate because they're
taken from the card drawings and then
put into a 3d image so what you see in
terms of the perspective drawing us how
it sits in relation to two storey
aspects next to it I don't have the
actual height of the apartments but in
terms of the housing need and providing
the affordable requirement these are
affordable units and line with the
housing officers core mates that's how
we deliver it by a three storey
development you can see it there yeah
that's really the central part gives a
focal point around our central square
and the broad networking development in
terms of the bread colors those
different bricks being proposed as part
of this scheme to provide for that
variety so some cladding some range
around two different cause of bricks so
the images you've seen will reflect the
type of brick that's going to go into
these plots yeah thank you for that just
the other one please Stuart you've you
obviously have got affordable housing
there which are complement persimmons in
doing 35% that's what we're looking at
however am I assured that you will be
presenting them the same as the other
housing that you are putting on that
site in other words or I personally
would not want to see a area that looks
different to what you've already got
because so many developments that I've
seen you can spot what isn't
actually which is actually affordable
housing and the prompt is as your
officer presented at the beginning of
the presentation indicated the
affordable housing units and then some
of the private housing units that are
all designed to retain your blind so you
would not go into development and
support an affordable unit they're all
designed in the same way with attention
to
detailing well swell three character
areas within the site it would match the
highest best vacation was storm cellar
cells but it will retain your blinds so
you won't be able to differentiate
between not in the private market units
thank you
you have one more and a final final
question and this is really a little bit
the way I'd like to see things and and I
would hope that you could go to
questions
the question is will you be able to
provide any Swift boxes in these houses
we we were you know we are losing areas
of birds in in ecology and I would think
that Swift boxes are very cheap to put
in on the when the construction starts I
can't remember whether the ecologist
statement which was submitted with
airline specifically mentions Swift
boxes but if members are minded to
approve and wanted to add a condition to
our affair to be quite happy to accept
that thank you
Kessler thank you just a quick question
really um can you just clarify the the
number of bedroom houses you've got like
the two to three bedroom houses how many
you've got of which sort like the four
the five bedroom and how many car
parking spaces you have with each one of
them please if you wouldn't mind - thank
you
the car parking spaces may be a bit more
tricky for me because oh and have that
information in front of me but as I said
earlier our policy compliance so they do
meet the standard set by the County
Council I'll just run through the table
I have before me here so in terms of one
bed apartments that are eight for
affordable rent the to bed apartments
there are six affordable rent the to bed
houses there are six market homes
sex affordable rent six intermediate
giving a total of 18 at the bungle is
those two bad bungles
- affordable
and to intermediate the three bed houses
there are 42 market homes for a fair
affordable rent one and two media giving
a total 47 3 bed houses earnest or full
bed houses there are 17 market homes so
in total 65 market homes 26 affordable
rent nain intermediate houses given a
total 100 just following on from that
question how many
dwellings are in the blocks do you know
that apartments the yes sorry okay yes
there are six to bed apartments and the
three-story six to in each level okay
cancel it so on their basis will see
square metre each of the apartments they
vary depending on the size but they are
compliant with national space standards
affordable houses
I think the smallest one is 50 square
meters or 51 square meters can't
remember out of size to be fair but but
they well default discussions with the
affordable housing officer and they all
meet the requirements say it by the
council Thank You Chancellor Aires thank
you I'm just it's lovely I really love
the way you can the outside is going to
look exactly the same between the
affordable and the
and the inside with the same fixtures
and fittings and flooring is it all the
same yeah by and large I mean for the
market hoses customers cannot spec so
they can have a better kitchen if they
want there will be a standard kitchen as
offered in all the houses the furnish is
pretty much to see him again in the
bathroom you can upgrade to better tiles
or whoever you want to however much you
want to spend to make it better but
there will be a basic standard in all
the houses which we similar through all
the floors thank you and the other
comments members attend to the Jemison
in terms of energy efficiency what
measures have you taken can't see any PV
panels on the or electrical charging
points again on the outline client
permission condition for thinkers
requires us to submit details on
renewables so that will have to be
submitted and agreed with the council
Thank You councillor Busby
you could go to slide 16 together look
at those three story again please
okay it looks to me there's only one
entrance which I find will be strange
it also looks to me as though all of the
apartments are the same size the
apartments are the same size yes and
there's one interest to the rios not in
the front of the building as to the vo
so there's only one entrance to this
building
those are Cornell entrance one entrance
yes is there not unusual for flies that
fire compliant I will meet the building
rare chairs are thoroughly balconies on
these on these the are little balconies
just Juliet balcony effects on the
images you can see running down the
second one and on either side they've
got glazed panels and frontal and Juliet
balconies but not not balconies per se
they've got Gardens I'm just wondering
where people are gonna dry clothes
something as simple as that but they'll
have tumble dryers and within the house
as commonly er say the bike but there's
no designated external drying facilities
okay so we've got affordable flats that
are very small in size that you think
they're going to put in a tumble dryer
which is the most energy inefficient
device in the home to dry things I just
don't see that I mean if you drive
around Pinewood where we've got flex
life I'm supposed to be I am told was
strange and I do agree with you
wholeheartedly that if you've got a dry
clothes most people want to dry them
outside or hang them outside we'll do
something but we are straying I'm told
so hence lopaka thank you
I've got the benefit here looking at
Google map so I can see the site and see
all the houses around it and things so
do you have any notion of the density of
the development well at little Tufts do
you do you have any data on that on what
I'm thinking is in terms of this
development in keeping with with the
other but you know what the density is
of housing around the site I don't have
these specific details the the one that
has been constructed recently completed
I think his Theatre Development 30 DPH
in terms of little Tufts itself I don't
know the specific densities didn't we
have a figure from the parish council
but it's 18 28 across cable in general
its twenty one boundary out which is
very dark very dense and cramped is is
28 and have questions
with those questions to you now I'll
trade well unless you want to answer
that one yes sorry it was just expired
in the density issue you mean the hoses
that were built in cable sent merely as
there were many many towns and villages
often danger country were built at a
time when density was much war and
nowadays in terms of making best use of
land the densities do tend to increase
and what you got to plan for is develop
was as an immediate context of the site
we don't believe that the density
figures of twenty DPH moving up to mid
thirties for the developable areas is
unreasonable in this particular instance
I think we all have our pipes to do on
density fellow take your point counselor
Busbee go get back to the open space and
the attenuation it was the same with the
proposal from Bentley why do you guys
think it's a good idea to book play area
close to the what is like to be a a pond
the drainage strategy says that the
point will only be a pond and an event
so we dry most of the year and except
when there's a storm event and it fills
with water so we'll not have any water
in it it's also a disappointment raised
by parish Kane so I'd like to see there
won't be fenced off as well be a post
and real famous can reindeer to stop
people going in there but certain times
or at least warn them away from it so it
will be protected but it is next to the
open space area because most of the year
that will double up as additional open
space thank you any other given that
we've had three months of rain there's
at least a quarter of the year where
it'll be full of water and my
understanding is that there's a bin upon
the question considered as the area for
many years any other questions
No thank you very much we've no twenty
counselor counselor carpenter has sent
her letter in and are coming soon your
table pages okay right we're now go into
debate counselor Davis I've seen it's a
question to yourself or mr. Duprey um is
it within our gift if we were to refuse
this to actually put a recommendation of
the amount because like you like the
parish council and the residents and
councilor Carbondale I feel it's very
very cramped and I know they've got
permission for up to one hundred but is
it within our gift to recommend a
smaller amount I'm not sure I'll get
legal about thirteen two days but I
think we can do further yes I mean if
they have permission for up to a certain
number whatever that number is then that
unless the council's going to modify the
permit that the outline which is this
never happens in real life and wouldn't
need the Secretary of State's
involvement so that's just for the sake
of completeness and remote theory and
the number means they have permission
for that number and obviously you can be
mindful of the size of the dwellings and
say well some of them need to be of a
smaller size to make way for the
necessaries or open space or space
between dwellings or groups but they we
are bound by the number we have the that
has been permitted in the outline thank
you
I think we have a little bit more debate
because I think there is a fear land
that members are not happy but did you
wish this can't play comment now or
later just to try and frame the debate
chair so if I'm understanding it right
members are some lenders a disquieted
about the the density of the scheme and
the size of the units etc and all said
that no
number of bedrooms and so on I would
suggest to remind you there is room for
up to a hundred which dasya an applicant
can take to mean a hundred thirty-five
units are affordable so we're talking
about sixty-five market units and the 35
have have responded to the needs
identified so our strategic housing
teams looked at that and outlined that's
been decided so those units are they are
content with those so we're really
talking about 65 units and we've gone
from being concerned that something too
big and some too small and it's not
clear
therefore what members would expect from
what's being offered and I think the ad
appeal the appellant may state that
they're just implementing what they've
got permission for and there's not
really apart from that house indeed 7 to
2016 there's not a background document
which was justify refusal based on Tim D
for bidders for example we can compare
with the Elm set application which we
had last committee there was a
neighborhood plan there that been
adopted and actually spoke on these
issues the Capel and they've put plans
at very early stages regulation 14 so it
carries very little weight at the moment
so you'd have to consider exactly what
you're arguing about for us then to take
to appeal and argue for the inspector
thank you I think members we we ought to
have a little bit more debate on this
and see if we can find some common
ground where we agree or disagree and
perhaps then seek legal advice at that
stage whose mates Council Osborne think
of it's Janet just a something that sue
cont'd others is brought up and agree
with her this should be clarified and
that is the amount of lighting it
two-foot ways whether the Suffolk County
Council
and to actually take to adopt them and
what what lighting is they going to
adopt if any right kind of help on that
Thank You chair yes in the event that
the application is approved and Furman
goes ahead post construction the roads
would be offer for adoption apart from
private drives so the actual main roads
you see on the layout would be would
have street lighting and also the
footpaths and that cycleway network
would have low level writing as well as
per the Suffolk County Council
requirements so mr. chairman and that
will be up for adoption with with
Suffolk County Council they've agreed it
or not they were as I understand the
process the developer offers the roads
for adoption to the council the council
goes out and inspects and if they're up
to a certain standard they meet their
standard then they adopt that they're
asked to adopt and they ruled it and
thank you very well clothesline thank
you
any other questions I've got a question
I am NOT happy with the design of the
block of 6th Whelan's I think the design
there on a new housing estate in the
place like a pulse of Mary near the
little Tufts development that's looks to
me like a center character so III mean
I'm not personally happy with that and
the other point is I would like to see
more bundles I have to remind us all
that we have to deal with what's in
front of us but they're clients that
that I would have concern on councillor
Parker saw your head yeah I think Joan I
think it's it's right that in the
interests of balance we do you know we
do explore this quite a bit further
because I mean I mentioned about density
only because I was just been curious to
know
you know what the density of the
development was next door but the point
fact is as our officer was pointed out
that you know we do have outlined
planning permission so a developments
got to come in there and this is what
we're being being asked to look at
undoubtedly it is it is of a higher
density but I actually think that the
officers paragraph 12.3 in his
conclusion is absolutely pertinent where
the officer says importantly is
considered that the impacts of the
development on the amenity of existing
residents in the prisons vicinity 77
sorry would not result in material
detriment so whilst we may not or well
okay whilst we may all have differing
opinions about the density of the
development that's being proposed I
don't I'm not I'm not seeing anything
here that is going to give us material
reason to refuse what is before us I
think it's yeah it's difficult I in a
perfect world we would like to see the
density of houses that were built in the
nineteen in the nineteen sixties and
seventies but I you know in the 21st
century that is not gonna happen with
regards to viability so I'll just you
know not I'm not saying anything more
than that at this stage is just to say
that just to remind you no not the
members need reminding but we are
dealing with what is in front of us and
what is in front of us isn't directly
related to the immunity of the
development that sits to the side of it
what one other point I will make chair
I'm looking at the colored drawing
that's on the planning portal I don't
know if we've got the colored drawing or
not but whilst we have a far more
densely populated area in terms of the
housing there is also undeniably there
is also more green space or there
appears to be according to the drawing
so just just highlighting that check-ins
Thank You councillor Ayers and yes I I Q
unconcerned about the flats the six
flats and I wondered if because I live
in a block of four flats but we have
special fire doors and there was no
mention of the fire prevention and I
have to worried about the one staircase
because in flats normally you have
thicker doors don't you it's it's a fair
point counselor it's when those
situations we've strayed into other
legislation if the buildings don't
comply with Building Regulations fire
regulations they're not going to get
certificate and though you'll be allowed
to live in them that will be picked up
any other councillor David yeah I just
like to pick up the point on twelve
point three page 77 so the point that
councilor Park has just made and I would
take issue that and I'm not going to
sort of say the officer was wrong but
however I think that the impact on the
nearby residents has been made very
clear to us in this application and in
previous applications so I'm not sure
what the evidence is that there wouldn't
be any impact of the amenity to the
existent residence in the facility
because I would suggest judging by the
parish council has said District Council
Merced and my own experiences visit in
that area that they would be and the
second point about the density and yeah
I appreciate that it probably couldn't
go back to the nineteen sixties density
but this has already been highlighted
nearby developments newer developments
are a lot less dense than this
particular one so I'm really
uncomfortable with this thank you I
think a lot of us are I never caught a
chance another time I think you just
want to register my concern I don't
think it meets I know no this is
immaterial but don't think it meets the
needs of the population that is
developing capable
Larry and hence I would support your
comment on the lack of bungalows thank
you thank you any other comments
councillor buzzer I know the officer
referred to the housing needs survey for
2016 from cable but it is the latest one
that we've got our Dylan's I think the
applicant hasn't done one so we have to
use the figures that that are there in
case it hasn't changed that much
we need starter homes like most places
and houses to downsize to that's
important I don't see this delivering
that we're here to determine whether we
think the design the lair of the scale
etc is appropriate I don't think it is I
think generally across the board I'm
disappointed I felt there's an
opportunity here for persimmon to come
forward with the scheme like they did
with Hadley which was innovative and
looked attractive and delivered what
people have Hadley wanted this doesn't
this does not match the quality of that
application in Hadley there are many
features in here that I don't like Lee
we've all mentioned the the three story
book of flats I can't see how it's just
a simple thing but drying washing if you
drive through Pinewood you'll see blocks
of flats like this and washing is
hanging out of windows it looks like a
slum even new flats look like stuns when
you've got lines of underwear hanging
out
it's just not appropriate I don't think
we've got a very good layout of the of
the village in terms of this development
in terms of the park it's not clear it
is on the documents that are only the
website and hard to interpret are you
concerned at the moment and I want to
ask I've been told are I could ask for
deferment on this I want to know what
the legal requirements is and if I
choose to go down that road with your
input members and we chairman is
perfectly up to prop up the committee on
any apple matter before it to say we
want to defer this because we've got
concerns we want more information we
want X and y looked into but it's I
would suggest you do fightin that needs
to be some definition of quite wide wide
deferments considered desirable I'm also
just checking under presuming other any
time constraints over these reserved
matters approvals so we could defer this
if we had some reasons our concerns
which you could go away as officers and
talk to the applicant are indeed yes
right well bear that in mind members
I'll go to the case officer for him just
to come in and I do know penciler Parker
I'll come to you meekly after us Thank
You chair it's just a number of points
that were raised by committee and I
think it's important just to respond to
some of those before you deliberate
further with regard to the block as I
said in the response sorry in the in the
initial comments in my presentation it's
an unusual building fair to say within
the context of the village but within
the context of the development that
you're being asked to consider it's not
unusual
as an element of that we're comfortable
that that scale of building that size of
building can sit in that development
quite happily without appearing in
Congress I accept if that building was
literally picked up and put somewhere
else within the village then the impact
of that you know in some cases could be
amazingly harmful but within the overall
context of the development that's being
proposed we're quite happy that that
sits there well the other thing to bear
in sorry to interrupt you there but just
on that point let me come back I think
it's fair to say that is an opinion yeah
we members have expressed a different
opinion so I just put it in balance
that's all I'm saying
you're right to do what you're doing but
I think it is an opinion member members
and if we want to discuss that in a
moment we can carry on the other thing I
would say with the drawings have been
produced in the the darkness of the
building what they're not showing of
course is that the actual type of brick
in this area you have a palette of
bricks earth called bricks and you have
multi Reds so I would venture that the
building itself doesn't look it wouldn't
look that dark once he was constructed
but I understand the point I'll just
quickly go back to the issue of amenity
because I think that that was raised by
a counter in a point and I'll go back to
the the layout plan the colored layout
plan which probably been more helpful
the issue of amenity in relation to
impact on surroundings and the point of
access was considered at the outlined
stage and I haven't checked the report
at the out on stage we consulted
environmental control with regard to
traffic movement in and out and noise
impacts on little Tufts those sorts of
things and it was found through the
noise reports and noise investigation
that most of the noise
managed from the a12 road rather than
from the traffic that was going through
at that point so respectfully I'm not
sure that that particular point can be
revisited with regard to use of little
Tufts what I would say is that in terms
of amenity one of the key things as I
said in the report is the amenity of
people along here shouldn't be harmed by
the development in the case of this area
you've got single-story development so
obviously a lot of the overlooking and
impact is designed out there's a
dwelling here which is adjacent to a
dwelling there where we've considered
the position of windows and again I've
said in my report that the way the
windows work in the internal
accommodation they're not actually
giving direct views through amenity on
the south side you've got long rear
gardens here which you're obviously
distant from the edge of this
developments are there for their amenity
is not adversely impacted and obviously
you've got the intervening hegemon trees
and lastly that area of open space as I
said into the presentation is designed
in not least to create a nice arrival as
you come through as a cyclist or
pedestrian but also keeps the
development away from boundary Oaks
which is sitting just about there in
terms of the density issue the reason we
are happy with this is that it is a
higher density than the adjacent
development but in all honesty
development of that density I don't
think is likely to be taking place
unless there was an enormous amount of
land available in order to do so in this
case we've got an area that's defined
for up to 100 houses the developer has
shown a scheme that secures a hundred
houses on there and also indicates open
space to serve that development which in
a way makes some sort of logic to the
overall use of the site and
so potentially could be a benefit to
people traveling through the sight
distance pedestrians and and cyclists
and just to clarify another point while
I'm thinking about it it is a leap at
the top not a lap so there that's that
secure board condition I think that's a
sorry the other thing is parking on
Plock parking is provided and where it
isn't in accordance with our standard
and where it isn't provided on plot it's
provided in parking courts and also
along the spine roads there are visitor
spaces so again I understand locally the
concerns around parking because I
understand that there's parking issues
and the councilor alluded to that at a
visit but we can say we can give you the
advice that it does meet your standard
and in a way that has not given rise to
concerns from the highway Authority so I
would just sound those advise those and
put those into the mix as I think in
terms of that gives you some background
as to why we were comfortable with
giving you the recommendation that we've
given you thank you thank you ken server
Parker Thank You Chet I really I'll just
make the point cherry that I think the
general direction of travel with regards
to the conversation is you know it's one
that this is not a particularly favored
site but I would just I would urge
caution it's not for me to allege
caution but but I think one thing I said
chair because you know it's entirely
within the gift of this committee to
decide as long as it's got reasonable
planning reason to do so it's entirely
within the gift of this committee to say
that it doesn't like this development
but but what's the alternative I think
it's too easy to say well that's not our
problem go away and and rehash it but if
a hundred dwellings on this site is an
issue what are we thinking they're going
to come back with half of that for
example so I just I just urge caution
members mm-hmm I hear what you're saying
cancel Parker I think the the impression
I'm getting and the feelin of God is
that the block which is six we don't
particularly like that we would like
more bungalows and I think the design of
some of it is enjoyed now whether that
could come back with a lower number or
not I don't know but that's why I feel
pres we could asked our officers to go
away the the applicants agent is in the
room he's here on these comments and the
expert that he is because we know his
plan his plan and history he will
understand where were coming from
and perhaps hopefully they could all get
together and talk this through and they
may come back with something a little
better I don't know that's my feeling of
it that whether you want to go down that
road or whether somebody prepared to
move a recommendation or not as for the
Davis yes so um could I ask you office
to show on the map where these planning
courts are could maybe I'm just missing
it but I can't see them and secondly
could I suggest that an environmental
report on the end of a quiet cul-de-sac
is not going to produce any noise levels
they can hear the a toll from that but
once that has opened up and the traffic
is going through little Tufts it's an
entirely different proposition thank you
any other comments oh you've claimed to
have you yeah thank you Jeff yes the the
parking courts are these areas that are
colored in to the rear of frontages so
you will see this
two areas there there's an area there's
an area over there which is a parking
court there's further parking courts
here
so there's several throughout the site
and as I say the remainder are on plot
directly in front or to the side of
dwellings just to go back to the little
Tufts point again as I say and if
members are concerned about that means
of access to the site my best advice to
you is that that has already been
rehearsed at the outline stage
unfortunately so you know we have to
accept that the council has previously
granted vehicle access to take place off
of little Tufts whether we now like it
or not and that's the not necessary the
constraint but that's the fact we have
to work with with regard to a reserved
matters application Thank You councillor
Busby yeah I guess my older state that I
do live within about a hundred yards of
this development but that to me gives me
an added advantage in that I know the
site and I know some of the issues it
won't affect me in any way I come out a
different way traffic well topic what
happens to me however we also turned
this site down because of actus well and
it was an apathetic application for a
hundred and fifty so we'd have the
committee has had issues with access but
that's by the way this is about this
side I joined this committee because I
wanted to deliver quality developments I
do not want to be driving round Baber
people saying look at that thing who the
hell approved that and that to me is
what would happen if we approve this
layout and design things there's scope
for it to be a lot better than this the
land law the landowner has got more land
beyond if need be you can see from the
from the
lay out that there are hammerheads there
which are presumably there for future
aid development so he could put more
land available to make it a quality site
Capel is taking a lot of extra houses
it's already a hundred and twenty five
hundred and thirty in the last twelve
months or so it's got five hundred and
fifty in the in the local plan it's got
another hundred here it doesn't deserve
to have poor quality developments as
well they should be quality developments
this has got some work to do I think it
yes it needs more bang closing yes the
the the flats should have some space for
people to either sit outside to dry
clothes or whatever not just overlook
car parking spaces there's work to be
done on this I'm not happy with this I
know it's very difficult to perhaps to
defend legally but that's the way it is
I think first of all we have to deal
with what's within the red Larkin
secondly I think the only way forward or
one of the way forwards is for us as
members to give the officers some
instructions but fins that we're not
happy with to go away and have a
discussion with them so that we're not
closing the door down with a refusal or
our approval at this stage and see if we
can get any any improvement because I
personally don't like the block of flats
there at all know whether there is any
movement on design whether there is any
movement on the amount whether there was
any move and that there was a third
point which I can't remember at this
moment but it will come back to me
yeah help us a well I don't know about
help you out here but I just need to
clarify with councillor Busby that you
it is an interest that you're declaring
on that point you do not feel that it is
going to predetermine or change your
influence your opinion on how you will
determine this application no that's
right no I'm just needed to clarify
thank you
he made it very clear he went out from
another direction and so members
what is the steer we can give to our
officers to go away and have discussions
which would allow us to defer it or fail
at that you have to make it as in one
way or the other so cancel above them
cancel Osborne yeah thank you miss jeren
you know I totally agree with with what
you're saying here I understand that
it's it's had an outline permission
however some of the stuff there does
need to be altered and I'm not happy
with that block of flats I think it's
far too large and again the amount of
affordability in there is all based on
stacking up flat sea in a block off a
block of flats basically but you know I
totally agree that our negotiation
should take place with our offices and
that of the developers right I'm gonna
now ask the officers clearly can you go
away with those reasons that I've
highlighted to look at and have a
discussion with them and we can go for a
deferment deciding in the the bungalow
question and then see I think was the
third one that was the third one
you know mixin type of dwelling CSE 18
chair if I may so our is there a way you
want to go this are you saying you want
more three beds two beds rather than
four bits is that a tough way you're
saying you don't like the design the
flats that could be tweet are you saying
you want more two and three beds and
fewer four bits is that is that what's
being said here I don't think that is
being said at this stage we just want a
better mix if you do away with the flats
it may be that you put him some
bungalows or maybe you put in some
smaller dwellings and we don't want to
tie their hands to that at this stage do
we okay so the buzz people well
the survey says the survey says that
it's starter homes and downsizing I
would have thought more two bedroom
houses bungalows were the kind of thing
that we should be requiring 42 plus 42
three-bedroom and 17 four-bedroom you
know that's what it's a 59 percent of
the total are not complying with what
people are saying they want to me that
isn't the right kind of ratio I would
have thought we ought to be looking for
at least 60 percent if not 70 percent
should be two bedrooms or single bedroom
places not three and four so I think the
mix is totally wrong and of course if
you do that if you go to two bedrooms
from four to three you will actually
provide more space it'll look less
crowded because the house is a smaller
so you know that a design can be
sympathetic to the to the mix and to the
layout as well
thank you I hope you enough yes Jarrett
Justice moment really the document we
have supporting this stance is the
housing new server for four years ago
and there's there's no SPD no policy no
neighborhood plan so it's it's a thing
but you know it's
has some weight but and but will go away
and do as you ask could I suggest that
we wait until another one has been done
no no I think at the moment for the
chair I think I'd like to propose that
we go for a deferment and we ask the
officers to investigate with the
applicant those points that were brought
aid so we're not closing it down we're
not saying they've gotten approval or a
lethal at this stage and to bring it
back to us at the earliest opportunity
sorry charity stand clear could you
could someone just summer was exactly
what points you want to be addressed so
I'm absolutely clear when I would
reengage with the developer please well
I think the fear that has come through
that we don't like the design of the
flats and that it looks too cramped
whether that's to many large houses or
not and that we'd like more bungalows
well which is part of the mix or the mix
and obviously that the applicants
perfectly tired to go out to a hundred
but if they're smaller or there's a
better mix that it won't be so many but
he may even want to consider and it's
his option yeah to build funeral homes
there I don't want to add that into what
my deferment but he's heard that comment
so is that acceptable was that enough
for you to work on that's what I need to
know if I may paraphrase so deferral for
design of the flats altering the mix
towards lower number of bedrooms already
better than that and increase the number
of bungalows yeah that's what you're
looking towards which we discuss with
developers
though this is for deferment now I think
I'm a terrible criminal and I'm sure the
rest of the committee are as well it'd
be the best way of going forward on this
application and I'm sure our officers
can do a good good negotiation with our
with our developer and also don't forget
the Swift pop season thank you
right has been proposed that we go for
deferment all those in favor please show
good as unanimous that's that's very
good fake home kids for Parker
they can I suggest you take this up with
the officer afterwards and yeah okay
he's noted it so hopefully he will try
and act on it thank you
right members that will come back to us
in due course hopefully as soon as
possible but we have to wait and see
great members we're going to move on to
the last item here which is on page 81
and it's Samantha over to you thank you
thank you just a point of error on your
reports in the strategic planning policy
consortiums they have quoted a policy
that is no longer valid its policy at HS
oh three this application wasn't
determined using that particular policy
CS 11 was put in place and supersedes in
this application seeks outline planning
permission for the erection of up to 19
dwellings on land east of the barn in
Essington the members carried out a site
inspection on the 29th of January six
affordable dwellings would be required
on the site with a commuted sum to make
up the remainder of the 35% provision to
be policy compliant other financial
contributions would be collected by a
SIL 28 residents have objected to the
scheme and there has been one letter of
support the Parish Council strongly
objected to the scheme and highways do
not consider the site to be sustainable
in transport terms the site is located
to the east of the barn the access point
would be from the street just here
the site is located outside of the
built-up area boundary which runs along
the street and is within a special
landscape area which is shown as green
on that plan the site is some distance
from flood zones 2 & 3 so there's no
risk of flooding there is a listed
building just here heritage do not
believe that the scheme would impact the
setting of the listed building at all
the barn which is a pawn shop is here in
the car parking area for that shop is
just there Essington is a small mainly
Linea village with a public house church
village hall and farm shop this aerial
photograph shows the rural nature of a
Singh ttan with many fields containing
orchards around the area in 2015 a
planning application for a change of use
to the land to the east of the farm shop
was granted the permission allowed for
22 touring caravans or tents 19 static
caravans and 22 storage caravans the
applicant the applications like that
we're looking at today is outlined in
red and it would be the site of the 19
static caravans you can see these
storage caravans just along this
boundary and the mobile pitches just
hear the pitches have been conditioned
to not be permanent dwellings also in
2015 permission was granted for three
dwellings just--hey the car parking area
for the farm shop it is just he the
northern dwelling
is accessed from the car parking area
and these two further dwellings have
their own access to the north of the
site
so the pawnshop is just off the plan
here eight dwellings have been granted
they have their own separate access
point onto the street in 2018 and Leiden
planning permission was granted for
eight Wellings
to the south of the farm shop the pawn
shop is just here and this development
joins the three dwellings that members
saw that have already been built during
the site visit later in 2018 a further
outline permission was granted for seven
dwellings which effectively infills
between the eight here and the further a
dwellings in this section he leaving
just this site that we're looking at
today for the touring caravans and
static caravans the new access point for
the development would be through this
area that has already been granted
permission because the all four of these
applications have been put in as
piecemeal development affordable housing
has not been claimed on any of these
developments so far
this is the existing cyclin and shows
the farm shop three dwellings that are
already built the eight dwellings to the
south of the farm shop and seven
dwellings directly behind the farm shop
that have not been implemented at the
moment that is my understanding that
they will be coming forward for
development very shortly this is the
proposed layout this is an indicative
plan only and shows how the site might
be laying it out but the final layout
scale appearance and landscaping would
be subject to a reserved matters
application if this outline is approved
members are considering the suitability
of the site in 19 dwellings and the
access point only the access would be an
extension of the previously approved
access point from the street past the
three dwellings and through there the
existing farm shop entrance would be
closed up so this new entrance that
hasn't been implemented yet would serve
the palm shop and also all of this
further development
the application site is outside of the
existing built-up area boundary and
protrudes into the countryside as shown
in the local plan from 2006 this is the
proposed built-up area boundary in the
new joint local plan in drops at a
moment although the draft local plan has
limited weight and decision-making at
the moment it does show the council's
direction of travel in the future both
of these plans are in your addendum
papers as it's quite difficult to see
the colored lines the members should
note that we do have development already
granted in this section here and RP the
access point from the street with the
palm shop on the left and the
development of the three houses on the
right moving into the site this is the
access road but one of the new with the
three houses on the left hand of the
right hand side though these are the
three dwellings that were granted
permission in 2015 this is looking from
the access point south down the street
this is looking north and you can see
the farm shop signage just here this is
the farm shop complex with the car
parking area this is the access that
would be closed up once the new
entrances have been installed the access
point to the site at the moment is
through this archway so through the car
park and through that artery and
background this is the site where the 15
dwellings already have permissions that
haven't been implemented yet and you can
see that the new the ropes are fencing
ism
this is the application site roughly
taken from the middle of the site
looking north this is taken from the
southeastern corner and shows one of two
concrete pads that have been installed
for the static caravans this is taken
from the southwestern corner of the site
the site is well screened however
caravans have a height of around 2.5
meters the dwelling even a single storey
would be double that height and would be
much more visible in the open landscape
this is the other concrete patch that
has been installed in the southeastern
corner of the site looking north within
the site the blue car and caravan are
roughly where the new access point would
be through the edge this is looking
across the site from east to west with
the building on on the streets just
visible I can just see the rooftops this
is looking into an adjoining field to
the city to the east of the site and
this is a paddock to the north of the
site no local needs survey accompanied
the application as engineers a small
village with many planning permissions
at the new dwellings still to be
implemented in very close proximity to
the application site itself a further 23
dwellings have commissioned the site is
within a special landscape area and is
outside of the built-up area boundary
and is not included as a land allocation
in the joint local plan the development
is considered to adversely impact the
character and appearance of the area
because of its scale density and
location it is therefore considered to
complete with the development plan and
the NPP F and is recommended for refusal
there is an error on page 96 of the
recommendation
refusal policy see no.6 should be
admitted there is no harm identified to
the listed building in the streets I
apologize for that mistake I understand
that members have previously refused
applications for a lack of local needs
survey this could be a further reason
for refusal should members be minded to
refuse the application thank you thank
you we have the Parrish pencil mr. Hill
thank you
good morning thank you for letting me
speak today on behalf of assitant Parish
Council and local residents 28 residents
have formally objected to this
application some time ago one resident
did give qualified support but this was
contingent on the complete change to the
application which has not been made
given no changes have been made mr.
Miller is here today to object
Azen to speak as an object at the parish
council feels that the officers report
is a fair and balanced one and therefore
I am here to highlight key points and
give further context the Parish Council
has supported about 50% of recent uptick
planning applications and we're
supported for sustainable development in
the parish however the council strongly
objects to this application formerly on
three grounds number one there's
substantial harm to the landscape and
village character this is cause for the
location of the application being in
open countryside visible from a number
of public footpaths as well as the
playing field and private Gardens it's
in a special landscape area and the open
countryside forms a key part of the
character of the parish the application
site stretches will be on the victory
estate towards a certain book and will
be on the small closes which have been
given recent planning permission is
therefore very different to nearby
applications which have been granted
permission and it was severely damaged
the landscape character yeah applicant
relies on the fact that there are static
caravans on the site cover me
there are these are no more than two and
a half meters in height and therefore
can be screened with low hedging houses
clearly a seven meets in I cannot be so
screened substantial harm would result
our second point is about the
unsustainable nature of the location
bassington has limited facilities and
minimal local employment the local
school is four miles away but is
oversubscribed
the bus service is being cut by chambers
currently as the officers report
acknowledges residents in the new houses
will be totally dependent on the
motorcar the existing static caravans
are only used seasonally as you can see
in the photos actually there are no cars
on the site at all permanent housing
clear clearly will be used all year
round so we expect the new housing will
result in an increase of 15% - the
traffic gained through the street this
is on top of 25% increase
from other building the streets is
single-file in places does not have
pavement on the vast majority of it and
visitants have to walk on the road to
access the pub and the church it's
extremely dangerous we have speedy
traffic like many religious do and
particularly to push chair and
wheelchair users Suffolk highways agree
and say clearly it's not a sustainable
location our third point is that there's
no dispensed will need for housing in
the village baby's local draft plan sets
a minimum housing requirement of 38
dwellings we have a neighbourhood plan
which is reach this pre submission
consultation stage and this sets out
sites for 67 dwellings the voters
therefore be successful in identifying
sustainable locations for the Vermont
and I therefore implore the committee to
reject this unsustainable application
thank you very much aha remembers any
questions transfer Park Thank You
councillor Hill with regards to your
neighbourhood plan you say it's at the
pre submission consultation stage whilst
it has limited white for the purposes of
this committee nonetheless is there an
allocation have you allocated sites
within your within your neighbourhood
plan we have we have allocated sites
both which have existing plan permission
and also a site which doesn't have
planning permission so we have 67
dwellings coming to a certain paper have
said is at a minimum of 38 thank you any
other questions
cancel Osborn you thank you miss Jo I'm
just on on that particular comment we're
about against where this is of the other
proposed sites you know of can you tell
me that Olli are they within that area
without 67 hours you just quoted
certainly not I can't be saved in 2004
they were spread throughout the village
basically some are in this area
some of the tools the north end some
toasters he'll think thank you
any other questions parts but thank you
very much thank you we have an objector
mr. melih thank you the disadvantages of
the proposed development outweigh any
potential benefits I asked for
permission to be refused our fully
support the reasons given by the parish
council my written representation listed
items of public amenity and biodiversity
drawn from the NPP F which could
potentially benefit aciton the
application is not offering them however
in fact the applicant has taken an
important facility away from the village
by closing the footpaths along the edge
of his land I quote the consultation
comment of public realm there is no
public space open space provision and
public realm would like to see open
space incorporated into the development
this was written in September 2019 yet
it's brought no revised proposal from
the applicant the applicant has over a
hectare of green space
at the site such provisions does seem
necessary under the joint open space
strategy OS for where new housing
development is proposed consideration
should be given to improving existing
open spaces within the parish where the
development is located also the NPP F
for instance paragraph 1:7
or promote ecological networks I can see
no merit in the application I have in
the past discussed the amenity space
issue with the applicant he said he was
sympathetic in principle my suggestion
to mr. Sain would be if he wishes to
make a fresh proposal he could arrange
to discuss it with the parish council
thank you thank questions I've got one
for you you you commented the term a
closing of a footpath I'm under the
impression the end even closer footpath
was the county council can you just
confirm what you said there clarify for
me please it was a permissive footpath
that had been used for a long time and
it linked to parts of the village thank
you right any other questions members
okay thank you very much
now have the applicants agent mr. bong
Alvin yes oh no the procedure so I won't
be Peter thanks Jimin and good afternoon
members thank you for the opportunity
dress you on this matter as you've heard
the council have previously granted
permission for the use of this parcel of
land as part of a development for 22
touring caravans 19 static caravans and
22 stored caravans at any time that
permission has been implemented and as
being opera and is being operated albeit
not currently to its full potential when
you've seen that through site visits
however it is wholly capable of being
relied upon and does therefore
constitute a viable fallback position
which forms an important material
consideration when determining the
proposal with that in mind yet become
wishes to address the comments made as
to both the highways position and the
landscape impacts the proposal firstly
the site is not an undeveloped passive
land which is a point accepted by the
planning officer in the committee report
the council have accepted a situation
where 22 touring caravans 19 statics and
22 stored caravans and all the
associated traffic that would bring was
found to be acceptable and has
subsequently approved an additional 15
new dwellings in lieu of part of that
proposal also finding those to be
acceptable this application seek
permission to replace the elements of
the store and static caravans with 19
permanent dwellings where there can only
be a mirror in the likely traffic using
the site it would be no different this
cannot be considered to be harmful or
unsustainable an existing permission
does not appear to being considered at
all in the highway authorities response
secondly much is made in report and from
the presentation as to harm the result
to the landscape from the pose
development yet the argument made is
simply that dwellings would likely be
taller than the approved qur'an's so
must therefore be harmful
there was no assessment made of where
this harm would occur what the usual be
effected or where the dwellings would be
able to be seen from there are no public
footpaths to traverse this site nor is
the site visible at all from barracks
Road or directly from the street
other than in obscure reviews free trees
and which will subsequently be
obliterated by the otherwise approved
developments there are significant
hedgerows and trees to each and every
boundary of the site and it is entirely
possible designers proposal so is not to
be harmful in landscape terms indeed it
would extend only the same distance to
the east as the victory estate which
lies further north
new developments have been approved to
the west and north on his site so it's
unclear why this proposal was considered
to be harmful to the landscape when it
would simply be seen in wider views that
taking the context of those new
developments it should be recognized
this is an outline application where
specific details of the proposal are
entirely within the gift or the local
authority to control opportunities for
additional landscaping and then the
layout revise the housing mix and to
control the scale of the buildings and
their appearance all remain in the
control of the local planning authority
the applicant will work with the council
to develop specific details of the
scheme to meet their design landscape
and Holle aspirations for the site at
that stage members the applicant
considers his proposal to make a
valuable contributions the councillors
housing supply in lieu of previously
permitted units on the site and there is
little doubt the proposal can meet the
council's design and landscape
requirements it is well located relative
to the village
questions I've just got one which I need
just to follow through the public
footpath you stated no public footpath
was closed
barely minder you heard I asked the same
question to the previous speaker can you
answer that it was news to me chairman I
looked at my client at the point when he
was mentioned and he also said no and
the comment seemed to be it was a
permissive part not a public footpath
councillor Park up Thank You Ven
you mentioned just at the end there that
you were you think this will make a
confucian to the
housing need but just picking up on what
our officer said at the end of comments
in presentation I'm guessing from that
that there was no local needs assessment
undertaken for this application no
simple answers no it is really difficult
haven't heard the items before today as
well in terms of where you where you
sort of submit to providing a full local
needs assessment in terms of scale
development and also where there's a
neighborhood plan being developed
because the parish council comments on
this show already that there is a
significant amount of development that's
been potentially permitted that includes
some development on the adjacent part of
this site but that it almost already
meets the needs that they've identified
and actually more but yet they're still
allocating sites so it's you know is
there a need isn't there a need but no
we haven't provided a specific survey
thank you any other questions
hence the Osborne yesterday Thank You
mr. chairman oh I'm a bit concerned
about on page 84 ten infrastructure
physical infrastructure in relation to
public drains your water systems no main
sewage does that does that include this
site what the problem got is I've got a
web version list which doesn't page
numbers on so I've got me sorry the
officer behind you is gonna hand you a
copy with it page 84 paragraph 10
[Applause]
again chairman I mean this company comes
back to the whole point of allocating
development in the village for a
neighborhood plan if this there isn't
there infrastructure in the village why
are they allocating sites it's you know
there are ways and means of delivering
the drainage on this site that don't
necessarily mean you need to have main
strange to do so Thank You councillor
Busby regardless of whether we should be
building on this site or not the
previous houses that have been approved
and are being built on this note nearest
land looked to be fairly large housing
looking at the split of houses on here
there's not one two-bedroom house
they're all bigger than that very few
cut was a couple of bungalows two three
bunk voters given the fact that this is
a sensitive site and he wanted to
minimize the impact on the landscaping
wouldn't it have been better to go for
smaller lower housing you know I'm gonna
say to new this is an indication it this
is an outline application with no detail
and I think the strategic has most has
asked for more smaller units which is
entirely achievable there are there are
four bungalows in that space that we
suggested and there are two stroke free
Bay Terrace properties which could
easily be made to I think from the point
of view of revising the mix that that's
what I said in my presentation it's
entirely up for grabs and it's in the
opioids gift to ask for what they want
and have delivered on the site and this
is a suggestion thank you does that help
well yes but wouldn't it be nice if you
came forward with something that people
wanted rather than the thing that
provided the greatest profit yes we can
yeah we did I can say I was born yes
thank you just a very short question
really been I noticed on the agenda the
application subject to pre-application
advice
go forward with that this would that
have been helpful so I wasn't wasn't
subject to no I mean is it yes what
potential mean if we were I think from
our point of view when I first discussed
this with the client the position was we
have a position on here of 19 units
being permitted all right they were they
were seasonable occupation but the in
essence we were prepared to trade that
permission for something else if we were
going to get into the elements of detail
which we will do if we can get an
outline permission then we will sit down
with officers and discuss that mix that
design that layout and all the details
we just here to establish principles
two-story Thank You counselor husband
should this be approved would the
applicant be prepared to have the
previous houses to the 19 and then take
35% of that for affordable they're not
his he was he was the applicant on one
of those proposals both sites have been
bought by a developer that was bringing
them forward or bringing together but
unfortunately it when we looked back at
the position and I think there's a
situation in Newton very similar this is
the moment which councillor Parker may
know about the the sort of accumulation
of sites and bits of sites being built
on is something that Baber has now
seemingly switched onto and he's trying
to sort of collate stop people so but
but they weren't the same they weren't
the same applicant they weren't the same
developer when they were first proposed
I think we are providing six on-site
here with the extra point six five
provided by commuted some I think one of
the points mr. Miller makes in his
submission on the application is that
most of the developed a certain have
delivered absolutely no affordable
housing and that's part of the problem
but I can't offer that because he
doesn't own it Thank You councillor
Parker yeah thank you sure Ben if
members were minded to go against
officers recommendation for this it
would would see approval for 37th
Wellings that at that particular point
but no transport statement has been
provided is that correct yeah again it's
one of these things where the horrors
coins came forward late they weren't
asked for on over the previous two
applications despite the fact that there
were 19 units on this piece of land and
about at fifteen dwellings it wasn't
requested and it's again there's no
there's no threshold they've now asked
for it in February I believe it was
January potentially it wasn't something
we were asked to provide and we
potentially could have done thank you
remembers any other questions no thank
you very much we don't have the County
Council or present-tense the park of the
mangrove the Klan committee was chosen
to study remember so he's the local
board member we're now going to gender
debate we'll start with you mr. Parker
thanks ed I mean to a certain extent I'm
obviously I'm going to listen to the
debate unfold I would just say that
there there is compelling justification
given in the officers report to support
the officers recommendation to refuse in
my opinion on this I mean I'm quite
happy to listen to the dope debate I
always keep an open mind on these things
but you know just from the interaction
that we've just had we've been there
there's some of the highlights that I
point out obviously we've had no local
needs assessment on the application for
this there's no transport statement has
been provided it's already been
established that the application site is
outside of the current built-up area
boundary it's outside of the proposed
settlement boundary and the forthcoming
joint local plan and of course with this
application we the district doesn't have
a housing shortfall at the moment so
full policy weight it seems to me
applies what I would just say is that
assing ttan is a linear village and I'm
sure the officers will put the put the
maps back on the screen it's it's it's a
linear village and it has accepted a
tremendous amount of new development in
the past 18 months the parish council
might know if it's shown in the report
54 properties granted in the last eight
months and yet somehow Essington has
managed to retain its its rural feel
what what this application proposes to
do
as I just mentioned with been there is
if members reminded to support this
application it would plunk and I use
that word unreservedly would plunk 37
dwellings in a non linear form part of
which will be outside of the built-up
area boundary so and I will just mention
as well one point that was raised that
while ago with regards to sustainability
since since this application has gone
forward chambers buses have actually
there in a consultation in fact they've
consultation period has finished their
proposals from Jones as buses is to
withdraw the the daily bus service on
all but school times so in actual fact
the villages become less sustainable not
more sustainable so I'll leave in their
chair for time being I think it's only
right to pay paying cancel a park up
maybe refer to 37 dwellings we are
talking of 19 on this particular planned
application I know you've added them all
up I understand that but to make it
clear we are talking with 19 and the
other point you said 54 had been
approved do you know how many of those
have been actually built I'll be honest
with each era I don't I don't know the
precise figure of those at Bingo built I
mean there was that the the two that are
material to this were approved only last
week in fact for the full bank but but
but a lot of them have been built I
think we've all driven through the
village we've seen the new builds that
have taken place up and down the street
there in a certain thank you I think
what I was really getting at is that if
people built that the developments that
they got the permissions for it would
help us a lot but they get permissions
and sit on in some cases but I'm not
suggesting that's happened here at all
any other comments councilman Hammond
Thank You chair I'd like to address the
question to sound if I may
having listened to the plans foreseen by
the parish council itself and record oh
sorry having heard the parish counselor
and heard about the development when you
look at the highways comment that this
proposal the current proposal is not
considered a sustainable location from a
transport policy perspective in fact the
facts that are stated about transport
and access have actually applied that
those have not changed so they've
applied to every planning application
that's been put before you so that seems
a bit inconsistent yet 19 dwellings
doesn't actually trigger a transport
assessment exist such a small number of
houses however their responses taking
into account all of the other houses as
well and they felt that perhaps it would
have been helpful to have a transport
assessment because if the other
dwellings that have actually been given
permission however we are where we are
we don't have a it's not required by
policy and therefore we don't have one
any other questions
councillor Busby
yeah we should have this plan wouldn't
it be nice if we did have a plan
perhaps we are going to have a plan
which says these are the houses that
we're going to build this is where we're
going to build them and this is the kind
of houses that we want the size of
houses because quite frankly enough is
enough in a system they've got they've
done their bit why should we keep
approving extra housing on top of what's
outlined in a potentially our local plan
I think we should be much further in
what we allow and the kind of things
that they're kind of houses that are
coming forward we should be stating that
we unless the two bedroom door bungalows
or there's a mix like this
it's got no chance of approval not just
keep getting applications forward which
are for 19 houses the large houses which
go with the other 18 large houses which
don't really meet the need and are
excessive to a sentence needs so to me
the statement that they've done their
bit they've got them done more than
they've required to do easy enough to
say I'm sorry
I approve and approve the officers
recommendation in fact I've proposed the
officer recommendation so you've
proposed the officers recommendation do
I have a seconder for that I've got a
seconder
councillor I was bored sorry chairs just
to clarify as discussed earlier just to
go through us the chair and that would
be the omission of the reference to
policy see n06
yes and the addition of lack of need
servers Perseus 11 this is what the
officers that outlined at the beginning
you're both happy with that
councillor Busby in cancer I was born I
think thank you
I think they only come in - oh you would
have a councillor Busby is that
hopefully the more people sitting on
these or look at that they can see that
we are becoming a bit more wanting to
see better quality a better mix
more behavior more tea more development
when they've got the permissions to get
up and do them so I think the message is
getting out there hopefully anyway any
other comments
no but it's been proposed and seconded
that we accept the officers
recommendation for refusal and noting
those two policy number changes all
those in favor please show anyone
against that's unanimous
okay thank you I think we've got to the
end of it members there's no site
inspection next week so I'll see you in
a fortnight thank you